when it's quiet that's when it hits you
that's what I think that's what a lot of
people experience when they come back
from a conflict Zone you know the uh
everything that was life and death
everything that mattered all the noise
all the chaos all the people that are
around you that would die for you kill
for you you would kill for them uh all
these millions of dollars worth of
equipment and stuff like that you're
responsible for now are all gone and
it's just you
the following is a conversation with Ed
Calderon a security specialist who has
worked for many years encountering
narcotics and organized crime
investigation in the northern border
region of Mexico
I highly recommend you follow the
writing and courses on his patreon and
website edsmanifesto.com
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Ed Calderon
what does your experience in Counter
Narcotics investigating the Mexican drug
cartel teach you about human nature
wow I mean first off anybody can be got
anybody can be corrupted uh you know you
you work in that field and you you
realistically the training we got and
profiling and investigation and stuff
like stuff like that was basically you
learn from the older guys there
and some of those guys were already
corrupted from the from the start so
trust no one I remember seeing that
X-Files episode where that was stated
you quickly learned that even if you are
somebody that uh to your own mind
appears incorruptible
you know small changes happen around you
Wheels get greased money gets put in
front of you and or things get
threatened like your life
and uh sometimes a payment for some of
this corruption is just to continue on
living
you encounter people that seem
incorruptable that go through FBI
background checks that go through all of
the uh
the security measures that all of us
were put through through
um you know polygraph test and then
later on you know
it turns out they were on the take or
they became somebody that was corrupted
I think what I found out is that anybody
at any level they could be a very strong
hard to get person right now but uh
people get corrupted through their
families uh through need uh Mexico is a
place where a lot of uh instability
occurs
um so financial needs health so a crack
could form through the wall of integrity
and then over time it seeps in somehow
Mexico has a culture of corruption like
you know you have your kid that goes to
school at public school and you want him
to be in the morning not in the
afternoon School uh
time period so you go off and uh Grease
the wheels with the director of the
school people hearing this in Mexico
will nod their heads because this is
something that happens from early on so
there's a stomach that there's a
systemic and cultural thing to it you
know as far as getting around rules and
this happens because you know the people
are in charge in Mexico the government
is
you know there are their tandem amount
is trust between criminals and the
cartels down there for a lot of the
culture so people don't trust the
government and much less a criminality
so when you meet a person sticking on
human nature do you think it's possible
to figure out if they can be trusted so
you said um
anyone could be corrupted
you know how long would you need to talk
to a person
and you're even in your personal private
life just a friend
or is trust the thing that's never
really guaranteed I think God trust is
never really guaranteed I know a lot of
people are going to say that's a sad way
and hard way of living your life but you
know life experience at my end
you know people change uh you know the
Dynamics of a relationship might change
I look at people's character
specifically their past and past
experiences if I can somebody that
presents himself in front of you as uh
somebody but you quickly learn that that
somebody is just a mask or a Persona
that they kind of uh created for
themselves and they might not even be
aware of the Persona like is there some
deep psychological stuff sometimes I've
experienced a lot of uh failure in my
life uh you can see it in my nose you
know you can see it in my lack of a
digit you know
um the amount of uh
you know the amount of failure you can
see in somebody and how they wear them
sometimes is a pretty telling thing as
far as them being able to be trusted or
that you can trust their story or their
experience
and when I say experience I mean I've
met some criminals like former criminals
or you know some some people of that
background that I trust with my life you
know because they're not not reformed uh
but they figured out that that's not not
a life that can live long enough to kind
of continue on and and I've also met
people that are in law enforcement that
I wouldn't trust with my car keys you
know
um because uh you know whatever Persona
they adopt adopted over the over the
years
is a pretty good one pretty good mask
sometimes such a good mask they don't
even know they're wearing it and on top
of that it's not just the psychology
there's also in your biology to it I've
I've been very fortunate and deliberate
to surround myself with good people
throughout my life
but I've recently gotten to sort of
observe not close to me but
nearby somebody that could be classified
as a sociopath yeah and and uh and a
narcissist like I I don't want to use
those psychological terms but just I
it's like oh people you know come with
different biology too so it's not just
like the the trauma you might experience
in your early life and all the Deep
complexity that leads uh all the Deep
complexity that leads to the the
psychology that you are to have as an
adult but it's also the biology you come
with the the nature that you might not
just have the
the machine that can empathize deeply
with the experience of others or maybe a
machine that gets off gets a dopamine
Rush from the manipulation of other
humans yeah or the control of other
humans yeah I mean put an example of my
my own background uh my mom didn't have
a father you know she she uh he left
really early on in their in their
childhood you know my mom raised her two
sisters
and basically you kept the household uh
she was a great mom uh
she was a badass you know she was very
independent she showed me how to be
independent she showed me how to kind of
watch out for others and kind of build
me up in that way and uh I had a great
childhood as far as you know as far as
her and kind of like how she molded me
later on I figured out
that uh when I had my own kid
you know I I figured out that she was
basically trying to make me into what
she didn't have in a way
and if I can get to see somebody's
parents you know that's usually a that's
usually a sign of uh of something at
least for me as far as figuring out
where people are I think there's
something to be said about nature and
nurture and how some people come up some
people are just born with that uh
predatory Instinct you know uh and
you'll never know I mean they spend
their whole life practicing how to hide
it
uh but if you can figure out somebody's
you know background childhood where
they're from you can kind of tell
something about them you know I'm from
Tijuana you know I'm a Survivor that's
that's my background as far as where I'm
from
uh culturally genetically
psychologically
the full shebang yeah I guess some
people are born with a certain
predispositions and if they're in the
right environment some of the negative
aspects might flourish more than others
you know for me I mean I grew up
skateboarding in Tijuana
and I remember breaking into my first
backyard pool it was a house that a
cartel guy owned and we used to escape
the pool in the back in the back of it
uh so I learned how to pop open padlocks
uh with a uh with a small vehicle
hydraulic lift
and I remember doing that and uh later
on in life I got to train with people
from other parts of Mexico and
and work with them and I remember
pulling that trick off and they were
like looking at me like where'd you
learn that
like some burglars at Tijuana you know
and they're like wow that's interesting
like all all people from Tijuana like
that
and I said no we're not all like that
but I guess in some way we are because
you know
Tijuana produces some produces kids like
that yeah she produces like the
environment itself produces
uh produces a pretty specific person I
guess you know where our normal is our
normal or a baseline normal is way
different than most the trajectories
that you can take in life are um are
defined in a way that aren't available
elsewhere in the world yeah and so you
develop I mean that's part of that
psychological part of that is cultural
and so on
um part of that is the cultural trauma
but then also the ethical lines based on
the corruption because I grew up in the
Soviet Union there's the same kind of
understanding that there's some gray
area of corruption yeah there's always
it's always there like in the on the
outskirts or even in the center how you
can grease things that make things
easier and how it's like a personal
thing I'll just you know pay off the in
Tijuana we have more these as what we
call it you know when you when you pay a
cop off means a bite
so and uh but what's uh what's the bite
aspect so you get stopped from for a
traffic violation of some sort and the
cop walks up to you obviously you don't
say the word bite but it's like a it's
like a slang term for it
and uh he asked uh for your paperwork
and you know and if you get fined or get
a ticket you say can I pay the ticket
here is what they say
and you know put their money inside the
paperwork in hand over to the cops you
think it's you know I'm just gonna do it
and nobody knows you know but it's a
systemic thing everybody like a lot of
people do it and then they don't trust
the police because they are fed with
this
yeah I mean same thing was in the Soviet
Union it's funny but then there's
something inside you where that kind of
uh
those opportunities come like uh with a
police officer where you realize you
could just pay a little bit of money and
get out of a thing and then you realize
you can pay a little bit of money or do
a favor they get your kids in a better
school or something like that yeah but
there comes opportunities where you
where all right if if I do this little
thing I can make
I can get a huge promotion I can get a
huge increase in my power and get a lot
of money and something inside you says
no yeah it's not right yeah and I wonder
what that is that because like um
yeah I want because it feels different
than the legal systems when we operate
there's some kind of basic human
Integrity human decency I wonder if
that's like constructed or it's always
there if it's like again nature versus
nurture yeah I think uh you know for me
it was looking at seeing that in
somebody else that I kind of learned
about it
uh there's a man that I consider a
mentor a figure uh his name's lieutenant
coloneliz
he was a lieutenant colonel from the
army that basically came over and took
over the group that I used to work with
uh
he was you know Incorruptible you know
he was uh that that was the the essence
or the the aura that he projected
um the first time he the first time he
went off on patrol when he was placed in
charge of us I actually you know drove
him around Tijuana
uh he was one of those lead from the
front type of people uh
the amount of assassination attempts he
got it was basically a proof of how
uncorruptable he was because he kept
trying to pay him off and when that
didn't work they tried to kill him
several times I think the last
assassination attempt took the use of
his legs
and that man is still a dangerous person
in my mind but for me and you know
people can gather a little bit about my
background and where I'm from and some
of the access I currently have to train
the federal institutions here in the US
as far as my background and if I was
corrupted or not because there's a lot
of that out there
um the
the Catholic guilt that's kind of built
into some of us is always kind of there
you know
the devil was under the bed you know
uh so I I don't consider myself Catholic
consider myself culturally Catholic I
think is what what I kind of kind of say
with that I had a pretty good structure
with my dad and my mom at the house and
you know they never let me get away with
uh things
and uh I think my mom was pretty a
pretty big moral compass for me but uh
that Lieutenant Colonel uh kind of
leading from example and seeing his work
and how
how much profound change it caused in
the people that work with him as far as
you know we felt supported and we felt
like we had a guiding figure uh during
this
Tijuana was the most dangerous city on
the planet when I was working there and
he took charge what does it take to be a
man the lieutenant colonel
who maintains Integrity after
assassination attempts is it possible
for a normal human to do that or again
as a genetic that's an interesting
question I'll say this uh seeing him I
mean his last assassination attempt he
had they don't took a use of his legs he
was with his kid
uh there was a recklessness to it you
know I I can see that now like now that
I have enough distance from it I could
see that there's a recklessness to being
that way uh and also you put in Jeopardy
people around you if you take that route
so I think there's a sacrifice to it a
very powerful and hard one to make for a
lot of people uh
for me it was I wouldn't get picked to
get on on board with some of the
operations groups that I wanted to work
with because I was known for not you
know taking money or
not being trusted by certain older
segments of the of the organization that
I was with with stuff because they knew
that I wouldn't you know I wasn't on the
you know they I wouldn't get money
um so there's that there's there's
always a weird sacrifice to it and
you're almost kind of like masochistic
in that way when you
when you when you when you get
approached with it they're like why are
you being an idiot you know why are you
why are you driving around that beat up
car look at the Hummer H2 that just
drove in with the other guy that is
doing exactly your same job
um
Society Society there's a hole down
there
doesn't reward it or at least doesn't
see it in the people that don't take
that route in Mexico you know for them
is all cops are corrupt you know all of
them uh and
you know seeing it you know again from
the outside I'm not there anymore
uh there is you know there's almost like
a why didn't you Ed you know
um but it could have been easier maybe
or you could have you could have been
dead long ago you know because people
that are on the takedown there are
usually owned by one side or the other
and when that gets found out you know if
you have somebody that you're paying off
that uh hints you off of drug operations
of the area
your Rivals are pretty keen on killing
you money aside so like like a Hummer
aside how much of a motivator's fear
it's a big one you know uh I I I'll say
I you know for me like I didn't I didn't
think I was going to lift this E30
and I was sure of it did that concept
scare you or was that just a principle
of life
you're operating under uh
I lost my brother when I was uh 13 on
the two like you know he was 19. uh he
was like the uh
the VIP of the family you know
you miss him oh every day uh he was a
you know he was a you know
skateboarded BMX uh motorcycle Hunter
one of the best marksmen that I've ever
seen shoot so better than you had
everything yeah he was the best of us is
what we would say and uh when he died
there was a there was it's almost like a
concert at his funeral you know I met
three of his girlfriends that all
introduced themselves like the the one
you know yeah uh to this day every now
and then I get uh pull the side down
when I go back home and uh the uh your
Eric's Eric's brother you know despite
all the stuff that I've done I'm still
you know every now and then I get
recognized
um
that made my mom and my dad go into a
horrible depression and basically you
know left me to my devices when I was a
kid
um from 13 onwards
I had this self-destructive you know
aspect to me after that I think you know
so again something that's come up in
therapy you know after I've been gone
through all that
uh and had this notion that if I can
only die good in some way shape or form
or for something that it would it would
matter and they would kind of you know
look at me with the same reverence I did
with my brother
so dying
isn't the problem the goal of life is to
die for something good yeah at least
that was my
that was my mindset going through that
job uh I remember
I was in medical school before that you
know second year of medical school I was
doing pretty good and then 9 11 happened
and you know that wasn't an option
anymore for me the economy was horrible
couldn't afford to stay there so
I saw this ad in the newspaper and my
brothers my big brother who's still
alive and had to uh he's like
you know yeah you're not gonna do that
[ __ ] you know we wouldn't dare
and all of a sudden I was in a field
having my hair shaved off and a bunch of
the uh
Gophers the guys that later turned into
the Zeta cartel uh military men were in
charge of our training you know and I
went through that process in what field
were you and why is your head being
shaved and what the hell was going
through your mind what was the leap that
you took I was sold the idea of this
being a new Americanized police force
that they were constructing in Mexico in
Mexico
so Elite
yeah Special Force kind of prestigious
Elite uh the people in charge of our
training were a lot basically uh ex
Mexican Agape people Gophers are what
the Special Forces kind of originated a
lot of their members turned into the uh
The Zeta cartel so they were brutal in
their training we were sold this idea of
it being you know scientific uh edu like
educate educated based and like a career
path and all of a sudden we're in this
uh
refurbished prison that wasn't good
enough to be in prison and they turned
it into a training ground
and I quickly kind of realized that they
were training us to be a paramilitary
group not a not a community policing
organization which in my mind that's I
thought that's what we're going to be
doing what was the hardest process of
that training for you because this is
like uh
a fragile innocent boy becomes a man
kind of process it's it's uh they're
turning us into something that they
could use so it's a breaking noun
uh they break down the individual you
know it's uh physically mentally yeah I
think it's a
H it's a it's a half done initiation
process I think in a way you know
looking at it from now to the past the
uh
the Shaving of the hair the uh the
stripping off your identity you know
everybody gets a
gets a a number
um the uniforms the
running around and
and uh you know being treated like human
garbage the first thing they said to us
when we were lined up in that field was
uh
which means uh there's bread and Dick to
eat here and the bread ran out a week
ago right so
it was I mean I can't equate it to
anything in the military you're in the
United States because people down there
could actually get physical with us I
mean they could actually pit us and
punch us and [ __ ] like that which is
not allowed here anymore at least in in
in in most of the military isn't as
horrible as down there uh AK-47s being
shot around us to to simulate reality
basically causing hearing loss that type
of stuff
um so chaos
uh abuse really challenging you yeah
again physically and mentally and an
Open Door there always so if you don't
want to be here you can just walk out
and the more you go into it time-wise
you're more invested you are so
in a way you're kind of building your
own chains while you're going through
that process were you attempted to walk
out yeah several times several times uh
specifically seeing some of the ways
that uh
people that I thought were better
or stronger than me were walking out or
quitting uh because of something that
happened in there
was some sexual assault stuff happening
in there as well are you afraid of that
ball is you know you're in a place like
that and there's females in the in the
environment and some of the instructors
are doing what they do
so that was like a cause for alarm I
mean these people are in charge of our
safety and education and look at what's
happening here so you could see some of
the the smarter ones leaving you know
not not looking at this as a viable
choice for Life how did that change you
that uh those few months I had this
motivation this idealistic motivation in
my head you know of making a difference
and
they drill uh they drill a lot of
nationalistic kind of uh you know the
flag marching
it uh being part of a group and the
group being you know behind you and all
this what was the nationalistic pride it
was it in the nation of Mexico yeah yeah
so what's the vision of this great
nation of Mexico that you were did you
believe did it get into your blood it
got into my I mean it's an
indoctrination you know it's a it's a
paramilitary group so everything there
is basically modeled after after the
military uh so that's what they were
trying to kind of instill in US
I was a
I was a team leader in there after three
months basically I was
um
we went through a bunch of Trials
physical trials um and mental trials and
stuff like that and not some of us were
named team leaders
and I you know bought into it you know
I'm the uh
I'm supposed to be here look at me I'm
I'm making headways I'm I'm uh
I'm sticking out a bit you know
and uh I was pretty proud of of what I
was going through there uh six months
then you get the reality check when you
sign the dotted line and how that none
of it really meant anything as far as
what we were about to go out and do you
know
uh
an example of this we were trained with
a 92 FS Beretta which is a nine
millimeter pistol uh Italian made
we got to shoot 20 rounds out of that
gun
and then we when we got out we were
handed a Glock uh 17 which
um I've never seen one in my life
I was uh trying to figure out where the
safety was and
a few other people there were uh
handling those guns in a horrible manner
um
uh so we were very under trained under
equipped and there was a lot of
assumptions about what we knew and all
of a sudden we were being cast into this
the in the start of one of the
you know bloodiest and longest lived
modern conflicts in our history that
doesn't get called that but it's it's
basically been an ongoing war in Mexico
that uh
that is still to this day you know
amassing bodies so the Mexican drug war
the Mexican drug war which is
you know it's hard to pinpoint exactly
when it started because when I was going
through training there was already stuff
going on I went into training in 2004
and there were already you know
major cartel related events all over
Mexico by then but not at the at the
size or scope as I was about to go into
you know when uh
president Felipe Calderon kind of took
office down there and actually
officially kind of kicked it off by
putting the military in play as part of
uh as part of it basically militarized
the uh the drug war you know including
us who are the major players in this
drug war so the politicians the military
the police force the cartels all Mexican
then the United States
China just to lay out all the pieces on
the board first off there are giant
local drug markets in Mexico that uh are
fought over you know just local drug
markets that are huge in scope so no
exporting to other locations just to
start yeah yeah so um a big a big
problem in Mexico is basically those
local drug markets and an example of
that and when I have a lot of experience
with is the one in Tijuana which not
only feeds the local populace but also
feeds the populist from San Diego that
crosses down into into Tijuana and buys
their product there
um and now you know phenomenon that's
occurring now is a marijuana trafficking
is going from California down into
Mexico because they produce better weed
you know which is fascinating to see now
so there's already a channel and you
kind of like reusing that channel yeah
there's a lot of people in vehicles
getting checked when they drive down in
Tijuana is being called San Diego South
now because you know all the economic
migrants you know are living down there
90 percent of all houses in in Tijuana
new houses are being bought up by
Americans so that'll tell you something
about the impact and change that's going
on down there
so you have these local drug markets
that are being fought over
you also have these drug routes that go
through Mexico up into Mexico around
Mexico through the ocean and under the
wall you know drug tunnels
over the wall
and on backpacks
on migrants that go up into the United
States
not only do the cartels make money off
uh drug trafficking but also extortion
money laundering paid protection schemes
you know any mining operation in Mexico
will have to pay protection you know or
else it'll get hit
uh a lot of times money the largest
money makers for some of these criminal
groups are you know um protecting and
taxing anybody that goes across the
border so that's also a big issue uh and
it's not just again uh some Americans
think it's like the cartels you know
they imagine this single or maybe two or
three groups there's there's several out
there
uh I don't have a current estimate but
last time I checked it was somewhere
where in the vicinity of 50 to 70 the
different groups some small that just
dedicate themselves to a single little
town somewhere there are armed groups
that are basically in control of that
area to some bigger federations like the
Sinaloa cartel which is probably
currently the largest and most powerful
one in Mexico
and the new generation cartel which is
growing exponentially right now
so these criminal groups are are players
in that conflict
then
another player that doesn't get talked
about is politics politicians
uh there's a there's an ongoing
discussion that has been going on I
think since Trump was elected about uh
cartels being a terrorist organization
cartels being terrorist organizations or
not or if they fit that description
well um you know we are living through
uh multiple assassinations on political
candidates down in Mexico right now and
most of those assassinations are
motivated by one side sponsoring one
candidate and the other side sponsoring
the other what I mean by sides I mean
cartel groups so they're they have
elected officials that are on the take
and this is we have you know many
Governors who are under investigation on
the run or in prison right now
uh State Governors so politics is
involved and that's a big player as well
that doesn't you know when you when you
think about the cartel problems you
don't think well some at least some most
people don't think about that aspect of
it so to have integrity as a politician
in Mexico means
you have no protection and under
constant threat of assassination
we just seen the arrest and prosecution
of the head of all counter cartel
operations when I was active uh in the
form of Garcia Luna who was the he was
he was the guy Philippe Calderon who
kicked off the drug war that was his guy
turns out he was turns out he was on the
deck at a level is there like a spectrum
of how on the take you can be are there
ethical lines you can cross some of it
is money and then
is it possible to operate in a gray area
that does not
result in destructive ethical violations
deep ethical violations I have no idea I
don't think I don't think there is
realistically I mean anything that kind
of supports some of these groups you
know you're supporting things of a
horrible nature
uh they're I just posted recently on my
Instagram account of a lady that was in
Guanajuato
she's one of seven recently assassinated
women that are looking for their kids
basically
uh there's a bunch of uh groups and
organizations out there in Mexico and
some in Tijuana that I've actually
walked with
who are
taking control of trying to find the
bodies of their kids
that's her up there Maria Carmela
Vasquez a mother who searched for a
missing son was shot to death outside
her home
on Sunday her son Osmar Vasquez
disappeared on June 14th the 46 year old
woman is the fifth mother to be killed
this year while searching for their
missing loved ones she was a member of
the Pena missing person Collective
there's many groups out in Mexico who
basically have given up on trusting the
government to find their kids
um the number of missing in Mexico is uh
debated topic because you know the
government itself doesn't release those
numbers or at least hasn't uh done a
good job about keeping them and or
releasing them
um Mexico was a country that has
industrialized Body Disposal you know
and Tijuana we had these two maker the
legendary stew maker which is a guy that
basically
used Caustic Acid acid uh to get rid of
bodies at a massive level so there's a
separate operation for getting rid of
bodies and murdering at least at least
in Tijuana we saw that phenomenon and I
I it's it's obvious that it's it's going
on all over Mexico who's having those
discussions about
mass murder and getting rid of people
I've been reading a lot about World War
II recently and there's was aggressive
Innovation on the Nazi side of how to
get rid of large number of people
because For the Longest Time both the
Soviets and the Soviets were more brutal
with this it's literally it's a
engineering problem of how you kill a
large number of people and get rid of
their bodies so the Soviets were more
into
uh just laying people laying people down
into the grave face style and then
shooting them in the back of the head
and then doing that in that scale so you
just pile people on and then there was
obviously Innovation with the Holocaust
in terms of gassing people and all that
kind of stuff I'm not sure exactly where
these
tradecraft skills are coming from
specifically you hear discussions of
Israelis training some of the cartel
groups back in the late 90s uh
specifically the Ariane fuse cartel
there's a lot of stories about that a
security specialist coming down and
showing them things like how to make
caustic soda how to put rocks inside of
bodies and then chicken wire them around
and to throw them into the ocean or the
or Rivers so that their bodies don't
float
and when you kind of put rocks inside of
body to make sure the body doesn't float
so you uh you open up the intestinal
tract put rocks inside
uh you cut where tattoos are or you take
off hands and faces and throw them
somewhere else and you wrap them in
chicken wire so make it not identifiable
yeah and throw them into a body of water
and this is
this is a horrible thing but it's just a
craft it's a tree craft it's straight
it's it's tradecraft and it's uh it
there's there's a link to the EOS as far
as having that trade graph you have to
remember that uh the United States had a
thing called School of the Americas and
and the CIA and they showed things and a
lot of that stuff is out there in the
hands of people that are of that
generation
so yeah there's a manual there's a
manual sign uh like with chapters and
it's like how to get rid of the body
there's manuals out there under time
constraints or what what are how
identifiable can the body be afterwards
what what a geographical constraints all
that kind of stuff I think I think that
was common back in the early 2000s uh
and maybe the late 90s when some of
these things were going on
but they've lost even that as far as
respect for the government or bodies
being found right now you what you
usually see is just bodies being burnt
to a crisp and buried in the field
somewhere that's usually what you'll see
uh some of the groups like this uh this
woman uh that this woman belonged to
basically taking upon themselves to go
out to find uh clandestine Graves uh in
the outskirts of of the towns that
they're that they live in
um probing the ground with uh these
metal probes
and seeing if the uh the whatever they
encounter in the bottom of these uh
these clandestine Graves stinks or not
uh if they find IDs or clothing they
kind of gather that and they basically
present it to the investigative
authorities in the towns or the states
they live in which basically they're
doing their jobs
you know over 90 percent of all murders
in Mexico were never solved uh I mean
it's uh so they've they've even stopped
trying to get rid of bodies in that way
you know
how does a cartel
take power
how does he gain control of this local
area that you mentioned and then grow
get take control of a region
and how does it do so in this dynamic
relationship between
um
politicians and the military and the
police force it's a thing that happens
over time
there's always been a big effort even
when I was in uh to buy or own certain
members of the police force even weren't
going through training some people get
pulled out during training because they
were found out to have some sort of
parent or sibling that was a cartel
member or they uh their FBI background
check came back negative you know when
they were already in the training
program
um so I I think part of it is
first off they take advantage of the
fact that Mexico is a young country it's
a country of young people
um
we have a a big group of young people
that have little to no opportunities to
come up
uh when I was in when I went to take
that career path a lot of my friends
took the other option you know they they
went to work for some of these criminal
groups
um so they have this going for them they
basically have a lot of bodies to to to
hire cheaply and leverage in terms of uh
forcing those bodies to do whatever is
needed because the alternative for those
people is is nothing there's no options
yeah so you have a kid somewhere who is
working on a field you know or you have
a kid like me that was out of the job
out of school and the only options for
me was uh this bad in the newspaper
which seemed like a long shot or going
with uh some of my friends that had cars
now and were hanging out all night at
these uh bars and some of them had you
know just
Draco AK-47 uh pistols in their cars and
it would look cool you know so there is
a trajectory there's many trajectories
possible in your life where you could
have been still operating in a uh
criminal organization in Mexico yeah I
mean it's there's not a lot of options
you know do you think you'd be good at
it
I don't know I mean I'm pretty good at
what I do now which is teaching people
how to detect it and kind of fight
against it you know so I think uh I have
a sense that that
the skills transfer pretty well that's
also the dark side of this whole thing a
lot of the people that I used to work
with you know I I know things and I have
them training I had some specialized
training and I I currently do I've done
you know presentations for the Secret
Service and the FBI and you name it I've
gone there and shown them what I do
a lot of my a lot of the people that I
used to work with who are out of the job
are in the wind you know and some of
these people are way more trained than I
am you know uh
it's interesting what it the the reason
why I get so get looked for and they ask
me questions is because I actually have
the experience that my University was
the most dangerous city on the planet
and when people ask me about some of
that stuff like I could speak from the
experience as far as encountering some
of that directly some of the people that
I used to work with who were way better
at it than I am
are in the wind yeah interesting thing
in Mexico if you are the police
organization and you get
fired or you quit you are ineligible to
join another police organization that
that discounts you so for somebody like
me who was a professional
operations group member or police
officer in Mexico of that region
there's no options for me outside of
that
so they they themselves basically have
created this
inescapable box for some of these people
that go into that line of work and what
do they go after you know
I've heard offers of twelve thousand
dollars to join uh some of the
organizations out there plus you know
they get benefits not like the
government you know I'm still waiting
for my liquidation my my liquidation
check this has been out of it out of
service for like six seven years I'm
still waiting for my check
uh so some of these people it's obvious
that the opportunities are presented to
them out there are stronger you know and
again the youth is
what gets eaten by this war and that's
one of the main things that they start
with just the youth we had a phenomenon
in Tijuana early early night late 90s
early 2000s called the Narco Juniors
Narco juniors are basically bored middle
middle fat middle uh middle class or
upper class families had kids that were
bored and they just joined some of these
cartel groups
uh these cartel groups saw on them
opportunities to get into regular
industry to go through the family
businesses to kind of establish
themselves use
some of those businesses to store for
storage or figure out how to use some of
their transportation businesses for drug
muelling so this is how they start
in getting into different areas you know
that they regularly couldn't
and
you know that's how it starts you know
you owe somebody uh they get into paid
paid protection uh type schemes which
are also common all over Mexico
and uh sooner or later they start owning
businesses and they regulate some of
their income so they become part of the
uh part of the part of the local economy
in a big way
I had this experience and seeing a lot
where we're driving down this shitty
Street and all of a sudden it became a
cool nice you know little curvy High it
got like a highway type thing and I
looked around there's like this is a
nice Road
and the guy was with me said yeah the
cartels built it you know
um you go to some of these towns and
the cartels are the government there
they build the hospitals they built the
churches they built the schools
cobit happens they're enforcing The Mask
mandates you know they're out enforcing
forcing the mass mandates the
stay-at-home policies
they're the ones uh delivering supplies
to the the townspeople and bags you know
courtesy of so-and-so cartel
you know so they they they become the
the Robin Hood characters of their
environments if they're smart you know
these groups basically turn into that
you know Robin Hood you know stealing
from the rich and giving to the poor or
at least that's the projection that they
give
what's the role of violence in this
operation I am extreme uh you know it
used to be that there were rules as you
say like
you know don't go after kids don't go
after women but all those things are
gone now you know they had been gone for
decades I think
uh the escalation of violence you know
you kill one of mine I'll kill four of
yours you kill four of mine I'll go
after your family because you were in
hiding
um there's stories of uh high-level
cartel people getting their you know
sons and and daughters you know murdered
mutilated uh and revenge killings so
I think it's uh it's at a point where it
spiraled a lot of semblance of a rule
set as far as who can get exposed to
some of this violence
those highly produced Isis videos
where they show torture and executions
uh According to some of the sources that
I've talked to here in the United States
that we're looking at that phenomenon
they said that it seems to be that that
was influenced by some of the Narco Blog
videos that that were coming out of
Mexico early in the early 2000s
basically that some of these groups were
the first ones that got wind of the fact
that you can
export Terror or the horror that an
execution has through social media
way back when Facebook was a bit more a
bit more of a Wildland area you could
see these in news feeds uh videos of
executions tortures and stuff like that
coming out of Mexico on Facebook way
back when wow this was a different time
um the people who criticize social media
and the moderation is a tough
it's a tough job because the brutal
world out there I mean I remember seeing
some of these Isis videos on on on
Facebook way back when and they you know
they cracked down all that but uh one
that's kind of clear and I'll see I'm
not gonna say where to find it but
people out there might have seen it
because some of these videos get shared
through WhatsApp groups and
chat groups out there uh one of the ones
that caught my attention way back when
was a guy getting two guys getting
executed by a chainsaw
um and
you know people can kind of
thing imagine what that would be like
but uh this is produced on purpose like
this video it's a cartel group caught
two rival cartel members and a way to
send a message to those uh that rival
cartel is to basically execute these
people in front of a camera uh I mean
you can't get to your Rivals but you can
you can make them see what they're doing
or at least make their people look at
what happens if you you know invade
their territory
just an escalation of brutality in the
violence as well I mean and at least a
terror and then sort of mass
communication of Terror yeah I mean you
you have videos of some of these people
engaging in cannibalism in front of a
video to see how brutal they are or
uh people taking out somebody's heart
while they're alive you know and filming
it and you know it used to be social
media as a whole you'll see some of
these videos they would they would get
put down and and for in a few days
but now there's telegram groups uh
there's uh you know there's Live Leaks
there's a bunch of other uh sites out
there that kind of disperse some of
these videos and
it's basically a bulletin board for them
as far as you know hey you got into my
territory well this is what's going to
happen to you
is there a game theoretic
way to uh remove this kind of brutality
to de-escalate the brutality because it
seems like if a cartel takes
power that exceeds the power of
politicians in in a locality there's a
strong incentive to reduce the brutality
to uh to crack down on this kind of
Chainsaw executions you know uh there
was a recent leak of uh government files
come the guacamaya leaks it's our
version of WikiLeaks I guess
and it was uh mostly uh documents coming
out of the Mexican military
I haven't seen it talked about a lot
here in Stateside but it's a pretty big
thing down in Mexico
and in some of those documents it
revealed how
powerless the government is I mean as
far as the military goes so that's
another player in Mexico the military
the military has been out in the in
force in the streets basically doing a
policing role since Felipe Calderon was
the administration he basically
militarized the drug war
um Felipe Calderon was at the uh to the
right of the political spectrum and his
main rival who was his way to the left
is now in power
and one of the campaign promises he had
was to demilitarize the the drug war to
send the military back to its barracks
and all that and he's basically
continuing on they just passed the uh
some legislation that basically uh keeps
the military on the streets for a few
more a few more years you know
um
and I think some of these documents that
were leaked uh are very telling as far
as why that is
uh they have the military now has a vast
amount of power when it comes to
security industry I mean they're in
charge of building airports and drain
lines in Mexico now
um their document themselves show how
certain regions uh in Mexico who have a
specific military uh presence work for
one side or favor one side of the cartel
they're corrupted too
so there's these military forces that
are in part corrupted yes and the cartel
which operates with violence somehow
finding a balance between each other no
it just feels like throughout human
history there's a
dictators or leaders that come
into situations like this and really
crack down on the violence yeah uh so it
seems like that's not happening it seems
like there's a kind of uh Market of
violence happening here there's a
systemic Amnesia that happens every
presidency in Mexico
so uh president comes in he has five to
six years to do whatever he needs to do
and he does everything and as soon as
he's gone
everything he did even even the what was
working gets chopped off police
organizations get uh defunct or change
or their names get changed uniforms
change so there's a lot of turnover uh
everywhere every five years federally
there's a turnover and then things
change what about the cartels do they
persist the leadership persists I mean
the senior law cartel has a has had a
figurehead behind it since the 80s the
same one you know uh I mean it's a it's
a Federation of smaller cartels that are
all kind of linked up but the pretty
much historically who's considered the
head of the the Sinaloa cartel omayo
zambada has been has been there since
you know since the 80s so in a way yeah
he he's persisting he's surviving all
these uh presidencies
again these documents that were leaked
are a clear sign of what strengths and
weaknesses there are as far as the the
government's main weapon against some of
these criminal Group which is the
military
and if people doubt this they can look
it up now online because all these
documents are out there
um but you know just a clear thing
the Mexican Navy or the marina doesn't
work with the Mexican army they don't
speak to each other so that should tell
you everything you need to know as far
as uh trust that could be just
bureaucratic dysfunction they don't
trust each other
are they both struggling with the
problem of corruption some of these
documents that are already that are
already out there talk about uh uh the
ports in Mexico
which are probably the main conduit of
uh precursors of methamphetamines and
precursors of things like fentanyl into
the country they're operated and guarded
by the marina right so these things are
happening under their watch and then you
get uh talks of talk about the Army in
certain places basically working
uh counter cartel operations not to to
specifically one side not not another
you know as far as the Rival groups out
there
and we have a long history of some of
these groups going uh military groups
going rogue Los Santas are a prime
example of this these uh Special Forces
uh units that basically turned around
and went to work as bodyguards for the
golf cartel and then
decided but what they basically did was
an internship with a cartel you know
they went out there did bodyguarding for
the golf cartel
and then I realized it can do a better
job than they were doing so they started
their own
sparking off one of these again one of
the bloodiest kind of like uh internal
Cartel Wars in Mexico's history
who was El Chapo El Chapo was a part of
the leadership or at least a faction of
the leadership in the cartel it's a
Federation of different uh of small
organization well I'd say smaller girls
they just basically families or
organizations that could conform this
larger Group which is the Cena law
cartel that is based out of Sinaloa
basically uh
they are people that uh have a family
and power nucleus is there in Sinaloa I
mean uh
who was he I think he was a he was a
high level operator for the scene in law
cartel he uh he had his own drug routes
his own uh networks his family his uh
his family uh nucleus down there is
still in control of some of those
operations so his arrest really didn't
change anything
um but he wasn't The Mastermind number
one leader that I think the media and
the government kind of portrayed him as
you know who was The Mastermind if you
go down there and you read uh what most
of the uh Brave journalists in Mexico
that we have
as a another aspect of this war is that
a lot of journalists get killed I think
Mexico has a I think has some of the top
numbers in the world
and this is not no secret to anybody uh
El Mayo sambada is the is the name of
the the historical figurehead of this
cartel or at least somebody who people
theorize or suspect to be the uh the the
main guy or the main person that is in
charge of some of this criminal group is
he still alive
that's the going rumor that he's still
very much alive and the interesting
thing about him is that he learned his
craft in Los Angeles so people thinking
that seeing Laura cartel isn't a Mexican
thing it's actually
uh he uh he apparently learned a lot of
his craft from uh people in the United
States you know and that's the craft of
leadership the craft the business the
craft which of the craft the craft of
getting a product from Colombia putting
it through Mexico and the logistics the
logistics part of it
yeah and he somehow is uh
operating in the shadows so he's not a
known entity I don't have a clear number
of this but he was interviewed by a
magazine called processo in Mexico and
some pictures were taken of him this was
over 10 years ago probably and that's
the last time anybody's ever seen a
picture of them what's it like to be a
journalist in that so uh can a
journalist have a conversation with him
and live not unless he asks to to have
that conversation I think he he reached
out to this journalist to talk about it
um there's a
there's a media Wing uh to the work that
we do a sister page called demolar
and and it's run by some pretty good
people and the way we met is that that
was basically training them how to work
in hostile environments and they were
like oh we're gonna go report on cartel
activity in Mexico
and I was like you know that is
a year and a half ago a reporter went to
the president's Daily Briefing uh press
conference that he has they called him
la mananeras
president and the president um
and told him to his face like uh I have
threats on my life they're trying to
kill me
and it happened there's been a slew of
assassinations and murders of members of
the press all over Mexico it's not an
easy job uh
either they say too much or they say
things that favor one side or the other
which is another aspect of it that is
interesting I don't I don't consider
myself a reporter I don't report on the
news in Mexico I have friends that do
that very well I commentate on some of
it only
uh but you see a lot of these uh cartel
reporters go down there talk to a
specific side and basically speak one
side of the story and that is not
something that the other side wants you
know if you
if you go down there and speak to one
side you're saying what they want people
to know or hear so in a way you're kind
of spreading some of their cartel
propaganda in a way and that's how some
people
you know get shot
do you think it's possible
to go in there and have a conversation
with a cartel leader well Sean or
somebody like me for somebody like Sean
Penn this is what I will say uh after
after that whole Sean Penn thing I think
a lot of people would reconsider a
meeting with anybody of any level that
has any notoriety here in the United
States they don't they wouldn't trust
anybody to get that close
um there are people out there that will
talk to reporters and help people that
are working on a on a laboratory
somewhere in a hillside somewhere down
down south you know in the Sierra uh you
know low-level people that get
authorization to speak to reports and
stuff like that but they don't say
anything that isn't being taught or
shown in various different ways or
Outlets out there for them I mean some
of these guys have Instagram accounts
you know some of these guys that blog
about it you know they're not the
leaders Tick Tock no not the leaders I
think after what happened to tuachapa
Guzman I think that that uh that
opportunity that win that was closed uh
for for some of the leadership down
there I think I disagree I think uh
they're just more sensitive
realizing that there has to be a deep
trust it's not just anybody and not any
high profile I've gotten a chance to
speak to some very high profile leaders
that don't speak to journalists and they
understand the value of trust
if they have something to say which I
don't think they do you know I don't
think they unless unless at some point
in the future which is something I
suspect might it might be coming
that there is some sort of armed
intervention and or external attack on
some of these criminal groups
that really puts the pressure on them
you don't think there's a human aspect
to this of a human being wanting their
story to be known versus versus this is
different than the propaganda machine of
I have something to say I have some
message to put out there to play the
game of politics and power and money and
all that kind of stuff isn't there also
a human being underneath all that armor
that
for for the sake of perhaps ego Legacy
wants to be understood I think in a way
they already do that there's Corridos
which are basically Mexican folk songs
that get uh they get uh song about some
of them so in a way some of these some
of these singers are reporting on some
of their lives and it's like a it's a
great honor to have a corrido made about
you you know I somebody somebody made a
good read about me based on my
interviews right yeah I didn't pay for
it so it's a real one yeah it's it feels
cool so creating a myth the legend of
the man I think it's about uh I think a
way you can you can find somebody like
that is somebody that wants to get their
story specifically clear and straight uh
you know
coming from that culture and getting to
work for the government down there and
then not being not working for the
government down there and being on the
outside being critical of not only the
government that is in place now but also
the government that actually work with
uh I can tell you that there's villains
all over the place down there
everybody's a villain you know at all
levels in some way shape or form and
some of these people
I think in a way including El Chapo I
think that some of that that meeting was
about film rights and and stories and
being able to get his story out there I
think I don't I'm not I'm not too sure
if it's I wasn't there but I suspect
that some of that was going on
if you can bring an honest voice down
there they can trust to put that out
there you know I mean
I think I think you could try I'm
interested in that kind of thing I
um because ultimately in some of those
places like
inside a cartel at the very top is when
you can really look at the raw aspects
of human nature in a way you can't
necessarily elsewhere there's a youth
coming into power down there and when I
say a youth I mean some of the old guard
is going out and some of the new guard
is coming in an example of this is uh El
Chapo Guzman's sons who are now in their
own right kind of getting gaining
legendary status uh his uh his son there
was an attempted arrest on his son that
led to
the famous culiacanazo incident which we
are now learning more about because some
of the guacamaya leaks are kind of
speaking more about what happened that
day
uh basically a federal operation uh to
they say to to arrest El Chapo Guzman's
son
um
turn into a Siege to try and get them
free they called in the calvary
basically the whole of the scene the
lower cartel showed up to try and rescue
him
interesting thing about that is in
reading some of the documents and also
just seeing some of the videos and stuff
like that came out of that incident
the cartels were the ones evacuating the
citizenship from the area
they were the ones going restaurant to
restaurant thing if you want to exit the
city go through here take your families
get down but you have to leave because
the army's coming here they're going to
fight us
um so there's like a deep morality too
to all of that underneath the violence
there's a Humanity I mean it's their
home it is their home and they were
fighting for their home and they were
fighting for leadership from their home
uh there is immorality there is a
Humanity there and again
I don't if people want to paint them all
with the villainy aspects you know uh
that's I mean everybody's a villain and
every in somebody else's story you know
if we if you kind of look at it that way
people should check out your patreon
should you check out your field notes yo
you're a really good writer your
Instagram too you write about you have a
quote in your field notes about villains
quote I once worked for a villain a
savior just some and a biblical demon of
all to others a true product of his
environment
he was the best and the worst of us were
all potential villains in someone else's
story he would say to us as you as we
would head out into the unknowns that
the Knight had waiting for us it was
during one of these nights that looked
around me and saw horns and pitchforks
among my people and realized what he
meant
we were no Knights of the Round Table
whatever we were we were needed in the
end I guess that justified most of what
was about to happen uh do you think El
Chapo do you think people like him are
good or evil
I think there's no one without the other
I think there's a there's a cost to
there's a cost to uh their goodness that
they do you know the roads they build
the hospitals the career paths that they
pay for uh there's there are doctors in
Mexico that their careers were paid for
by some of these groups
uh and they do a lot of amazing good for
the community I remember there was a
a surgeon
uh reconstructing cleft palates
in one of my travels that I did out
there I I had I spent some time actually
going out there be after I got out of
the job to train people and the the type
of stuff that I show people and uh they
uh they told me like I told them like
you're doing God's work this stuff this
stuff is like legit this is God's work
you know building Smiles for people I
said yeah and then can I talk to you
yeah he said you know my career path was
paid for by
cartel a group of cartel members they
paid for my career path because they
wanted somebody on hand that could fix
their teeth
do you think some aspects of that is
just sort of manipulative control
or is some of it also just again a care
for the population for fellow human
beings that are one of your own I think
both you know I think there's again
that's hard to it's hard to just make
them Saints or Devils you know the uh
the the some of the good they do in some
of their communities and don't ask
anything for in return you know uh and
even if they don't ask it for anything
in return where the military shows up
they are immediately met with rocks and
roadblocks and everybody's uh
main weapon down there since most
Mexicans can't buy or own firearms
they're the main weapon down there is
silence and their eyes to report to the
people that they uh consider the good
guys in their environment right so
that's a hard question you know I think
I think there's a bit of both and both
the the government and the criminal
groups that are operating down there
silence is their main weapon
so El Chapo is currently in prison
is he worth talking to
I'd say yes is there things that to you
are interesting about him they're still
not understood
is he a window into something that you
don't understand about that will still
are curious about in that world I think
he's a window into the family dynamics
of that world I want to say family
Dynamics uh Mexico has a big thing about
Compadres you know and Hermanos like we
have people that we call family that
were not necessarily our family
uh he is somebody that witnessed the the
the construction of what is now
the Sinaloa cartel like he was in it way
back when he started off as a
as a farmer and then went into
trafficking he's uh from a town called
mandirawata which is basically you know
that's the uh the wakanda of cartels
basically that's where a lot of that
originates
um
the the things that he saw as far as how
some of these things got built I think
would be an interesting uh topic of
conversation with somebody like him so
that story is the story of evolving
family Dynamics yeah part of the story
of the cartel is individual humans
marrying other families uh getting uh
getting named padrino basically
Godfathers to other people's kids
um forming family and Blood Ties and
influence ties to people not only in
Mexico but in the United States it's
seeing how that Dynamic and family
Dynamic is still there you know so he's
gone he's in prison but he is
he's probably on his way to be our next
uh clandestine Saint you go to the uh
the chapel of malbert
malberta is basically a Mexican Robin
Hood the folks ain't down there who is a
saint of traffickers
and at his shrine
you have small little chapel
Shrine right next to it so he's on his
way to sainthood in Mexico you know not
not recognized by the Catholic church
but that doesn't matter in Mexico
anymore
speaking to somebody like him who
we can consider him somebody that lost
you know he's arrested but his family's
okay
his uh his legacy is out there he's
going to be named he's probably going to
be the next folk Saint when he passes
away do you think he feels like the new
wave of what the cartel has become is
betrayed him with left and behind or
um because it seems like the way the
cartel operated has changed over the
decades yeah well number one their power
and influence is bigger you know uh they
there are seen a lower cartel operations
in Colombia straight from straight to
the liking the source of it and uh then
there are clear uh they have a clear
presence in in places like Chicago and
Los Angeles uh they're in the United
States the whole
thought process that a lot of Americans
have like oh we don't want that trouble
over here we don't want them to get here
or like build the wall and all this so
they're deeply integrated into
legitimate businesses I mean they've
been having kids and families up here
since for a long time some of these
people have passed American passports
that work not only directly for them but
have Blood Ties down there you know
there's been dragnets and a rest of some
of these uh criminal organizations
Stateside New Generation cartel had one
two three years ago where
the guest operation Anaconda I think it
was called there was that over 80 of
their operatives and this is a new
cartel that is very militaristic and
growing in Mexico and they had over 80
arrests in the United States you know
that of members of them operating here
and so you could be a legitimate
operator inside the United States
that's hard to detect makes you wonder
how many in the US government
the politicians here is it is the the
role of the United States in the drug
war financially in terms of power is
very big yeah surely there's politicians
that have a finger into this immigration
is part of it uh illegal immigration as
part of it and the influence of that has
as a as a bargaining chip and a
political chip we saw this with the
first Caravan kind of coming up and how
it was politicized
the money fast and furious and guns
being basically let walk down into
Mexico people that don't know basically
the ATF had this operation where they
were looking at straw purchasers or
Firearms basically people buying up a
specific type of firearms that were on
the shopping list that the cartels
wanted to buy
including uh you know 50 cows
fn57 pistols which are small pistols
with a high velocity round that will go
through a bulletproof vest
um
AR-15s of all kinds that could quickly
be modified into full auto down in
Mexico with a with a drilling a few
holes and making a few things to them
so these people were buying all these
the ATF was watching them and allowing
them to walk those Firearms into Mexico
under the guise of trying to track them
somehow
which doesn't make a lot of sense for
most people to kind of look at that
operation the only people who found the
only reason people found out about it
was because of the murder of a few
federal agents of the U.S federal agents
that were killed with those guns one of
my friends was shot with one of those
pistols outside of his house and they
shot him and they shot her his wife both
of them were killed daughter was in the
back seat lost the part of her arm
when that happened the guns were unique
they were like oh we didn't never let
the Mata police yes is what they call
them they're the cop killers
I haven't seen those before
so they were unique and interesting and
later on in life I was watching CNN and
seeing the hearings going on I was like
oh that's where they came from
uh
two federal agents changed a lot it was
politicized there was a whole scandal up
here but in Mexico how many people died
with those Firearms you know being let
down being let go down there and also
what type of sentiment you think the
local populace has of the United States
after all those guns were basically
handed over to some of these groups
if gun trafficking is another GI part of
the equation part of the problem down
there as far as uh as far as the amount
of Munitions uh weapons and
now we were also getting uh tradecraft
material from conflict zones outside of
Mexico so
weaponized drones the first time we saw
uh some of those weaponized drones was
uh in Syria
and like like a few weeks later you know
grenades were being dropped on the roofs
of some uh public officials uh Bill
cartels are using drones that's been
going on for a while there's a place in
Michoacan and has some pretty
interesting videos and the the
interesting part of it is because the
federal police down there are actually
working hand in hand with a United
cartels Group which is basically the
local cartels to try and fight off the
new generation cartel moving into
Michoacan so even the federal forces are
fighting with the cartels to try and
keep this larger cartel out and there's
videos of these uh civilian drones
basically dropping explosives uh they
found some explosive testing ranges out
there that are basically replicating
stuff that you would see the IRA use
during the con during the troubles out
there from homemade mortars
um you know IEDs have been used in
Mexico that not that much but they're
they're making like a presence again you
know we don't have a lot of ordinance
around like Iraq but we do have a big
mining industry down there so mining
mining explosives of all kinds are
pretty easy to get
so you start seeing that and also I mean
there's some exotic Weaponry coming in
from the south now and from the ocean
now that some of it is probably a U.S
military equipment sold to various South
American governments that are now
not as stable as they were and they're
kind of making their way into black
market so a lot of those 50 cal and
vehicle mounted technical type machine
guns and some of the RPGs and
uh man pads or remote control guided
missiles that you that have been found
in cartel hands are probably come making
their way up from down south to get
these like multi-million dollar systems
like the high Mar system in the in the
Ukraine you get like super sophisticated
advanced technology or we're not so like
this is like military grade I'm not sure
what the applications would be exactly
in Mexico some are sophisticated stuff I
see in our man pads which is basically
remote guided missiles I've seen some of
those found out what is the application
exactly
a display of power there are no-fly
zones over parts of Mexico
for this reason the new generation
cartel took down a helicopter
there's been incidents of military
helicopters falling from the sky and it
it they said that it was mechanical
issues
but again I'm not I'm not gonna do
conspiracy theories out there but
there's there's a lot of videos on Tick
Tock of uh Cena Laura cartel forces at
parties you know carrying around uh
rocket launchers on their backs and you
know and so so there's an increased
probability of mechanical failures over
those areas when you're flying a
helicopter yeah there's no fly zones
over certain parts of Mexico okay and uh
um another thing you're seeing now is
night vision uh night vision equipment
uh that is clearly military grade from
the US that was probably abandoned in
some War Field out there so maybe
Afghanistan or somewhere like that and
it's uh it's being found in safe houses
and in the hands of cartel forces you
want to talk about a scary opponent
somebody wearing night vision
with a suppressed firearm those types of
capabilities are now out there
also there's this tendency to think and
every now and then you'll see these
cartel videos with these guys carrying
around these 50 cows and they show up
they stand there like you know the
boasting about the rifles and everybody
laughed at them because
the 50 cal or anything like that without
an optic on it you know is like you're
gonna shoot you're praying shoot
basically see if you can hit anything
with it uh but now there's a a few of my
sources I've seen you know sophisticated
uh laser-guided uh rangefinders and and
sighting systems on some of these that
are being found out there how much
damage can 50 cal what's the application
they started getting them specifically
with the proliferation of armored
vehicles in Mexico Mexico has a giant
industry and armored vehicles as far as
so there's a race in terms of uh
armoring like protecting especially high
value targets and then weapons they can
deal with those armored protected high
value targets there was a an attempted
assassination of a state prosecutor
somewhere in I think central Mexico I
forget exactly where but she was uh
riding around up armored uh Jeep
uh Cherokee I think it was and their
main means of of uh Firepower was 50
cows and that car was left in pieces he
survived in it so I think the armored
vehicle company that sold her that
vehicle has it in the display room
uh then before my time probably two
three years before I was actually active
they tried to kill the head of public
Security in in the state of Baja and
with him it was a grenade launcher 40
millimeter grenade launcher it uh it
skipped off the the armored vehicle and
landed in the the car behind it made the
back explode uh one of the guys that I
used to work with was actually in that
car he's arrived it
um but you started to see oh they're you
know using our vehicles now let's get 50
caliber now to try and defeat that armor
uh
so that yeah there's there's always this
uh
this race of Technology basically down
there armored vehicles
you know how to take on an armored
vehicle well there's a few ways 50 cows
you know if you can mount them in a
right way and shoot at a car like that
or a bunch of kids with balloons and uh
acrylic paint
on the front windshield and blind the
vehicle so it doesn't so they can't
drive it anymore there's another way a
tow line across a road painted like the
painted painted black so you can't see
it
and cut the thing in half again I'm not
saying any secrets these are things that
people have seen out there uh
the shoot at the radiator you know uh
some of these radiators are not uh even
the more sophisticated uh Vehicles out
there don't have a sufficient uh
armoring around the radiator or the
battery housing of some of these
vehicles
there was a case of a guy I think a
nickname was El pelalacas or something
like that I haven't seen a lower level
cartel guy he had a normal vehicle he
was you know riding around and he got
ambushed he shot at his car he was like
ah I have armor he can't shoot me and
somebody went up to his car and just put
the barrel right in the locking
mechanism
and that kind of you know so
it's an interesting place as far as
people getting certain types of guns
armor is prolific down there I mean
everybody down there look at all carton
levels you see them wearing Blade armor
so that's an issue it's not like you can
shoot somebody Square in the chest and
go down are they afraid to kill
Americans
so I know I was traveling in Ukraine on
the front
so like a lot of the journalists were
traveling like armored vehicles
and at first I was like it seems like
this would attract attention yeah like
it seems like they would want to hit
those targets but then then I realized
over time as I learned
there's a there's a fear of killing
Americans there could be a drastic
escalation of yeah it's not worth it
conflict it's taking a beehive yeah
it's yeah there's there's there is a
tendency to shy away or stay away from
that you know I mean these they don't
want the Heat or the attention outside
of that everyone's game everyone's game
but also there's been many cases of
Americans being killed down there I mean
we saw the Mormon Massacre uh that
happened down there and all of them were
American Mexican they had both
nationalities and blonde kids you know
white being a massacred in the middle of
a desert uh and the car is uh basically
Catching Fire this happened and you know
America the Americans uh sent the FBI
down there to kind of review some of
what happened down there
and uh I think that was when Trump
started uh talking about kind of
Reviving this whole notion of cartels
being labeled as a terrorist
organization probably more for other
political pressure point he was using to
try and get Mexico to reinforce its
Southern border which
it hasn't but there's escalation you
know oh this this already happened and
nothing happened so we can probably get
away with it you know and again there's
a newer generation moving forward now of
people coming into power more brutal
more technically Savvy well they have
the experience of their parents and the
people behind them and what they've done
and one gotten away with and now yeah
more Savvy about information Warfare
their main recruiting tool is tick tock
to go to Tech talk and you'll see a
bunch of these kids at a narco party
dancing around and some of these are
videos like cartel members filming other
cartel members in cartel control
territory and that's a window into that
life for
who's on Tech talk now kids
and the enticing aspect of that is the
money
the fun
the High Roller life and the possibility
of making it to a level you know yeah a
Fame of uh respect
power
money here in the US somebody might you
know I want a mansion you know like that
that's their mindset I want to live you
know like that rapper
down there I mean if you can buy a house
for your mom you know or pay off some
debts that you might have or a car
that's enough to kill for
so you also one of the many things you
did is uh you did security try to
protect in this in this war try to
protect people high value people yeah
how do you do you and others how is it
possible to protect a high value Target
like a celebrity or an important
politician in the situation so I was I
was tasked to protect the governor of
Baja and his family I was basically
replacing a whole contingency of people
that were already there that turned out
to be corrupted that wasn't my field I
was operational I was working with other
people doing the counter narcotic stuff
and uh the director of the institution
that I was in basically called me and
said hey uh
you're going to go and replace these
people and like what happened to them
well
so you were known as a person that could
be kind of trusted I was tasked for that
so I I think they considered that and uh
and I I specifically worked for uh a
governor named uh Jose
uh who was probably one of the best
Governors we have had in the state and
people want to see if I'm trustworthy or
not they can ask him directly and I I
still speak to some members of his
family and we're still you know friends
in that way it's protecting people like
technically a difficult problem to solve
for my experience in that time and in
place he was basically spearheading you
know counter the drug war in Baja when
he was in power so he had threats from
all over not only him but his family
first thing I realized working that job
in Mexico is that uh we had
we had people coming in to do
specialized training of that regard
Israelis you know teaching us how they
would do things in Israel that didn't
make a lot of sense for us in Mexico you
know uh we had people that had some
Secret Service experience kind of show
us how showing us how they would do like
celebrity the bodyguarding or
bodyguarding somebody maybe in
California of that nature
didn't make sense for us then we got to
experience some cross training with some
uh nsw Naval Naval special Warfare
people who were coming off uh protection
details in Afghanistan and Iraq is there
some useful crossover there we were
struggling with the acceptance that we
were basically doing protection details
in a war zone
so the approach
uh that had to be taken in Mexico with
some of the approach you were taking
Afghanistan during a war some of the
overt militaristic type approaches to
security that we had to adopt you know
from uh
we didn't move him in a single armored
vehicle we had two of them that looked
exactly alike so when we would move
around we would switch one card to the
other every now and then we would arrive
to an event they would open the door and
it would be one of us and they were like
Hey where's the governor he's in the
back one so he moved to that so we had
to do stuff like that
and again this is a young me who didn't
have any specialized training I was I
was on YouTube
learning learning some of these things
uh going online learning about armored
vehicles learning about architectural
armor I think you just described a large
percentage of the Ukrainian military how
they operate which is on YouTube trying
to figure out how to use some of this
techno and and uh that's actually
incredibly effective yeah you know I do
quite a lot of stuff where I'm totally
not an expert totally uneducated and so
on it's kind of surprising how quickly
you can get caught up as we're talking
offline if you take a course if you talk
to an expert if you learn from an expert
you can like catch up really quickly for
me it was all of a sudden I have this uh
director calling me in and I'm wearing
Vans you know in jeans you know t-shirt
and all of a sudden I had 80 80 some
people that I had to move around and I
was in charge of uh securing planes and
uh which I what do I know about that
airport hangers uh armored vehicle
maintenance and and purchasing and
figuring out how to set up a counter
assault uh group for for a protection
detail and I was like where I'm going to
learn all this
be able to quickly figure figure some of
these things out on the Fly basically
you know as I was going I remember
having this experience uh being in the
uh our security office on my laptop
figuring out how to set up a counter
surveillance uh aside to our protection
detail basically how to have people
looking for people that might be looking
for us you know type thing
and then going to
San Diego to Coronado
and training with some people from uh
former seal guys and NCIS people who did
that job in war zones
and seeing them
critique some of the solutions that we
came up with on the Fly and being like
Oh we never saw that before Oh yeah this
is we're doing it down there so getting
that compliment
and also getting their you know feedback
like we probably do this or do that and
it's it was a learning process on the
Fly that was pretty I mean seated your
pants level is it possible for the
family
and for the high value person to um to
have a sense of normalcy to have a
normal life I mean I tried I was already
starting off on the on the wrong foot
basically because trust had been
violated by the people that I was
replacing so I had to gain that back
then young kids in that family that
wanted to have a you know go out and
stuff like that in the most violent city
on the planet
so I had to do my homework and figure
out places where they were safe to go to
and
make friends with certain club Owners
and figure out ways to put Security in
some of these places and having to
create this bubble of normalcy around
some of these people was pretty
difficult and uh there's no way that
that is uh a normal for anybody and
and oh God you know God bless them the
the I know it didn't I know it wasn't
easy and I know that it affected our
lives and they they lost on a big part
of their youth being under that that
security supervision and bubble
does probably does a lot uh for for
somebody specifically growing up like
that you know uh you lose opportunities
of
things that we take for granted you know
just going up just not telling anybody
and going to the store you know because
you want to get some snacks or something
like that that's not available to some
of these people
I have to be honest when I was in
Ukraine that was a really big benefit
you'd Escape no I couldn't hang out I
couldn't eat when I'm stressed I would
fast and not eat much so I get lost
weight this was great it's great for the
diet that's a good idea basically be
under protective custody that's a that's
a that's a good idea for a good yeah you
diet and just life it allowed me to
focus get a lot of reading done uh focus
on the important things in life
I mean uh I joke of course but there's
some
there's some complexity to this in terms
of normalcy of the family
but also just how to operate like have a
mental Clarity and a lack of fear just
basically be good at your job whatever
that job is if as a politician as a
leader uh even as a soldier somebody
that I like and I think this believes
that Ola said this to me or said
something like this to a group of us
that there's nothing wrong with being
paranoid it's about educating your
paranoia and knowing what to be afraid
of
if you're afraid of everything you know
you're basically overwhelmed but if you
start educating yourself as far as
specifically what to prioritize as far
as what to worry about
in a war zone working protecting
somebody you know you're not looking at
everybody's faces you're just looking at
their hands because that's what's going
to kill you
you know that's an example of focalizing
you know what you're paranoid and what
you're afraid of so looking at the hands
that's the specific to the particular
situation but also figuring out which
situations to avoid and which yeah it's
okay I mean that's like ultimately one
of the biggest things you could do route
analysis you know you you have to get to
the airport and you send off two cars to
analyze two routes and then on the Fly
you just change
trajectory to to create Randomness an
unpredictability and have that as a
security feature
um having to a convoy of four vehicles
separated into two convoys and show up
different in different parts to again
make it hard for people to guess where
you're going to be
pulling out false information as far as
who where it's going to be who's going
to be and that type of stuff it's kind
of amazing how many assassination
attempts Hitler avoided just by having a
pretty strict schedule and being a
little bit off in terms of timing just
like showing up 15 minutes late or to a
slightly different location we're going
through training uh specifically around
this type of stuff and and operational
training basically showing us how to
ambush people
you know when I started making a group
for myself as far as counter Ambush you
know this cat teams that they call them
up here in the US basically a group of a
group to respond to a high violent uh uh
Ambush first off the first rule if you
find yourself in an ambush it wasn't a
successful Ambush because if you if you
find yourself in it you're alive you
know yes but if you want to create an
amazing counter Ambush team you have to
you know you have to make them ambushers
and with ambushing you
figure out where all the opportunities
of not only successfully doing what you
need to do or in your favor but also to
escape with your life you know we're not
uh
we're not going to be received
vibrations in heaven we're not that's
not the type of mentality that we had
down there but uh
we start learning about some of these
things and also seeing you know cartel
forces apply some of these Ambush
tactics to the military or the federal
forces what is an ambush what are we
talking about so that's a surprise
attack with an asymmetry power kind of
thing there's a contingency somewhere
moving towards a place that you control
and own where you have the advantages
where they can't see you but you can't
see you can see them where they can't
predict you but you can predict where
they're going to pass go through you
know places where they forcibly have to
pass
uh places where they're predictable
places where you can not only predict
but also have a plan for yourself to
escape and exit that place so how do you
transfer Connor Ambush you turn into a
like a perfect ambusher that's how you
train for camera also always trying to
make sure you have more information
about other people you have the element
of surprise all of those things and
Musashi would say you know your enemy
know his sword you know but basically
that you know simplified there's a lot
of enemies around you in Mexico there's
a lot of uncertainty right because it's
well I guess that's what route analysis
is yeah you prepare for the probable
yeah and if the impossible happens
you're halfway out of it hopefully you
know and if you find yourself in an
ambush it wasn't a successful one uh but
you you uh as far as our training and
the kind of the mindset my experience
with it you the adversarial thinking
part of it has always been a very
powerful one I think one that a lot of
people ignore kind of like leave to the
Wayside
uh specifically in all conflicts out
there there's a tendency for a military
force or a conventional force of any
kind to be trained in a way where they
dehumanize the enemy yeah and when that
happens you become blind to the enemy
story it's his capability his story his
ability
uh you if you treat the other side like
an inhuman monster
it's hard to take notes you know so this
part of this is a radical empathy for
for
the quote-unquote enemy at least for me
personally uh I wasn't I wasn't one of
the guys that would be and grab them and
beat the [ __ ] out of them put them in
the back of the van just tie them up and
gag him so you're able to see them as
human I learned that from my mother you
know she's had uh nobody's against you
at there for themselves learn this and
you will you will make friends of
enemies
she said that when I graduated and I
carried that with me throughout my whole
career but isn't there then a pain of
killing another human as always but
there isn't again I apologize to go back
to Ukraine as my only experience of this
kind of harshness and it is a powerful
experience there's a dehumanization that
happens
I suppose this is common in war there's
something like a video game aspect where
people are almost having fun there's a
humor and I think underneath that the
prerequisite is to see the enemy in the
same way you see the enemy when you play
Call of Duty you don't really think you
think of them as NPCs the bad guys the
Russians are called Orcs
in Ukraine I mean there's all kinds of
other names for Usos you know malandros
mugrosos like 30 people you know there's
always something over time those are
just words but over time it gathers a
kind of
um like a meaning to it that's more than
just the words Orcs they're less than
human yeah they're dirty they're too
dumb to understand the evil they're
doing or whatever whatever the it's
useful it's useful it's part of the
program but like that's what I I've
talked to soldiers and some of them do
have stories of momentarily remembering
that there's a human on the other side
I've talked to one woman
who's this really badass Soldier and she
saw this Really Brave soldier on the
other side
do something that
was almost stupid
How brave it was
and then she was trying to shoot him and
she missed
and she said she could sleep the night
after
thinking
why did she miss why did she miss and
then she thought she missed because he
was a hero and she had this brief
realization that there was a hero on the
other side like the other side is Heroes
yeah and then but then that quickly
disappeared yeah again but she had this
moment as a human being that rises to to
defend his Nation to defend his people
and he could be heroic on the other side
there are things that we're trained to
depress or
conceal or hide and kill in us when
you're trained for something like that
or when you're in Conflict Zone like
that and you hear the narrative
constantly being blared out that the
other side is a orc or you know whatever
whatever word you want to use
but you know we live in a day and age
when you can see uh Americans going off
to Japan and shaking hands with some of
their former enemies I mean some of us
have seen that
and how things change I think years from
now a lot of the stuff that we are
taking right now is of the utmost
importance won't matter anymore the
question is how many years the question
that's a question I asked of a lot of
people
in that part of the world
and a lot of them currently they're also
self-aware about it they're like I'm not
sure I trust my current feelings yeah
but the current feelings are
generational yeah like for decades I
will not just hate
the the leadership I will hate all
Russian people I can't understand that
on my side of my life experiences
because you know our war has been an
internal War you know amongst our people
our monster houses why that is the
propaganda it there's also a deep grain
of truth that there is a Oneness to the
people of that region yeah but people
will get very offended at that idea
because right now it's a very strong
nationalist borders but there is a
cultural history
that connects people I mean in some deep
sense we're all connected we all come
from Western Africa and then all came
from fish before then depending on your
uh the review of of light of history of
life on Earth
um
but there is a Oneness to us and often
you forget that in Conflict I had an
experience working
there was a friend of mine who took the
other path
uh and went to work for some of these
criminal groups
I was operational and I was
we saw a bunch of people in a gas
station parked
back then the main you know Moses
operandi that they had was that they
would impersonate or dress up as federal
police
and that's how they would move around
the city
we saw these Suburbans in a in a in a
gas station
and some of the guys were carrying on
our AK-47s you know and that's that's
not a standard issue firearm
so
you know we saw that and I got off on
foot and walked by
to try and get a
you know better sense of what was going
on I took everything off uh wearing
jeans and a t-shirt
and I got a whistle from one of the guys
uh that was there and my name was called
it was one of the guys that I grew up
with
redhead kid looked like El Canelo you
know
uh there's redheads in Mexico by the way
I think it's probably some of the Irish
that uh that betrayed the American side
during the last mexico-american war that
stayed down there had a bunch of kids so
it's probably from there love is
stronger than anything else it says
redhead kitten and I said kid I mean he
was my age now to my eyes he's always
going to be younger now
he whistled
told my name
say hey
guess the key code I'm like what are you
doing here it's like ah She Gotta just
you know going home and she look going
to get a taxi
it's like oh okay he'll walk as he walks
over it's like he has a plate carrier
with AK round uh magazines on his chest
uh AK without a stock on it
he's carrying in his hand
he comes over and he hugs me I can feel
the uh the magazines on my chest
mind you I have a gun on me you know
tucked
and uh next Hill is buzzing in my back
pocket
as people are trying to figure out what
the [ __ ] going on
um he asked me small dog [ __ ] like hey
he's like what are you doing like what
do you work at I'm like I'm just looking
for a job you know he used to work at a
video store
so he's like ah but I haven't seen you
in a while
uh how's so and so of your family good
how's the answer of your family good
it's like yeah there's like this is an
interesting job you have he's like yeah
it's pretty good they pay us well and
get a you know you get a car you know
there's money
and nobody [ __ ] with you you get
respect I was like that's awesome you
know and if you want it can get you in
you know if you if you want that's like
Ah that's I'm too much of a coward for
that I told conversation like any other
yeah between two friends he hugs me
before I go
I just have something doing my I can't
remember what
and he says Hey in my ear I know what
you do for a living it's not a safe
place for you to be in
and I walk off
a few moments later the Army showed up
and you
could feel the amount of rounds going
off from two blocks away
we came back with our guys
then it was it was over
so he didn't survive that
I looked through the bodies and the cars
that were left you know there was
bodies all over the place people left
there
it was a mess
they spent like an hour looking for him
the only way I could recognize him was
his hair
um I stayed with his body
all night there's a
there's a bridge
in Tijuana that goes over the river in a
place called La Mesa
and that's where the forensic offices
were
his body was taken there and I stayed
with his body until it was released
I told his family about it
because I knew them
in that aspect of you know us versus
them or they're the enemy and she like
that
you know my mom
told me those words now nobody's against
you they're just for themselves so don't
make the mistake of dehumanizing anybody
and those roles could have been easily
reversed
I could have been shot in the face there
that aspect the conflict brings worth
let's say
bad guys good guys you know uh Heroes
villains you know I
there's an innocence to that that uh it
goes away is your mom still with us no
almost three weeks before I decided to
quit she passed away
did Dad have a role to play a major one
after I got done on the protection
detail with the governor
uh like everything down there again the
whole cycle you know he got his turn so
when he went away
uh you know poth exchange and down there
basically if you're uh can uh
gubernatorial candidate you have either
a friend a friend of a friend or a
family member be the head bodyguard guy
and
the guy that won the elections had his
head bodyguard guy already there so all
of us were sent back to the whatever we
came from so I went back to work on the
streets uh I was uh back on the
operations group I was working with the
sub-director uh directly with him
basically back on the ground doing
the stuff that I was doing before that
job we were moving away from the
successes that had been had by people
like lisaola when they were in charge of
that whole process the people that I
used to work with
some of the only successes in that
counter push against cartels in in
Mexico
and you can kind of like it's documented
you can read about it out there a bunch
of people wrote papers on it some of the
only successes were had by Lisa Olin the
places where he had leadership he not
only pacified Tijuana
he also did the same in Juarez he was
sent uh to be the police chief in Juarez
too but politics change and you know
Heroes become villains a lot of people
started calling him a villain because of
his uh unorthodox approach and human
rights violations and all this that type
of stuff kind of come through the
Forefront
and people forgot you know people forgot
what it took to get Tijuana off the most
dangerous cities list on the planet
and uh
people were vilified people like him uh
and uh the police force that I was a
part of started getting compromised
a lot of the things that were put forth
to try and keep us honest there was a
program they had these centers called
the c3s
basically you would go there every every
year you would get your financials
checked you would get a physical
psychological evaluation you would get a
polygraph exam done on you all the works
to try and see if you were somebody
doing something wrong
and all of that was canceled because
it violated your human rights if you get
uh fired from a job because of a failed
polygraph exam because that was not an
actual admissible way of firing somebody
so all of a sudden you had people that
were known cartel compromised people
that were fired five six years ago
showing back up to worship back up to
work
with their back pain and everything
so this is wow so it started happening
and it quickly I quickly realized that
it was gonna be hard to stay there
um
I was uh driving home from work and I
got a call from my brother
that uh
my mom had been going through some
health issues
that had turned into a psychiatric
issues so we were basically taking turns
trying to
take care of her you know locking the
door so she wouldn't wander off and
stuff like that so Not only was I
dealing with the job on the street but I
was dealing with that and also I had a
a two-year-old
and a marriage that was
difficult uh that had time
so I was trying to figure all these
things out made more difficult by your
job
yeah it's not a financially secure job
you know and the pressures that it has
and the odd hours and all that made it
really hard
and then all of a sudden um my brother
calls me and tells me that let's go to
the hospital with my mom something
happened to my mom
it wasn't my turn to watch her so I
felt pretty shitty about that
I got to the hospital and
the doctors you know came out and told
us that she was gone
it was a a massive heart attack she had
a pacemaker by then
so she was gone
that she was in her 60s so it was you
know we kind of expected something but
not you know that that was like
hard for me she was my
Center she was going to be the one that
would ask for advice as far as work you
know if I should leave it or not the
ground was removed already there was
nobody there was yeah there's nothing
underneath me
I get three days off work
that's what they gave me
and uh
I'm trying to grieve as I go back to
work
talk [ __ ] crosses my mind as I'm going
through that process of trying to figure
things out like dog shake like suicide
dark [ __ ] yeah so it was very low for
you very hit very hard yeah
I wasn't allowed to grieve basically and
I wasn't allowed to grieve for for a few
years uh for different reasons
I went back to work and there weren't
allow other people also you yourself
were not allowing yourself to grieve is
it like there's there was other people
with me that didn't allow me to grieve
you know
um I went to work got called into the
office and I was basically told that I
was going to be reassigned
after I just what I just went through uh
the reassignment was going to be
something that I saw as
unacceptable
it was uh
the people in charge at that point were
obviously corrupted
and what I got from their conversation
was that they wanted us to work for a
specific side
and I knew that that was the time to go
I
asked for a license basically licenses
uh unpaid absence workbase so leave of
absence I think it's what you call it up
here which by law is allowed
and I was denied
for no reason
so
I'm invested in this job you know
there's I have a I have a
I have a good salary a salary and I have
a category in there so you the by the
level of uh time you spend in there you
get a category so it was a pretty high
category agent
I had all this training and again
training that would be useless in the
private sector or in the in the public
sector in Mexico I couldn't change from
one Corporation to another and can go to
work for another police institution so
I took a deep breath and uh
I resigned
I went to the office I said I need to
resign they said what I need to resign
some of the people in the office that
knew me from a long time were like
what's wrong with you they thought I was
having a mental breakdown
hand it all over the all the paperwork
uh took a big trash bag put all my stuff
in there uh Blade armor to your gas
grenades uh gas mask
satellite radio uh MP5 magazines uh an
MP5 uh submachine gun GLOCK GLOCK
magazines all of it helmet
and I put it in the handed it over in
the Armory uh
and uh
I left
I made some phone calls
um
I was married to uh an American and my
daughter's American
I never envisioned myself coming to the
United States to do that process for
myself you know so I was invested in
that job I thought I was gonna
die or retire from that
and uh
it quickly became like an issue because
everybody's wondering why I left the job
so abruptly so
there were some threats made
when I left
by people inside the office and I
probably you know it's Anonymous yet to
their significant pressure not to leave
it's hard to leave this kind of job yeah
the system makes it difficult to leave
the individuals to the degree they might
be corrupted really don't want you to
leave there's no support yeah there's no
support and it's probably the opposite
of support yeah and almost like implied
or or explicit or implicit threats yeah
luckily I had developed some friendships
in the United States for some with some
of the people that I used to work with
and crosstrain with and some friendship
that I developed with people that I
would uh
just talk to and make friends with
stateside
one of them was a is a Navy SEAL
reservist whose uh name is Dan Stanfield
and his wife Kelly they
opened the doors of their house to me
and my kid and my wife at that time
as I seek to basically look for the
American dream
I crossed the border
with my kid and uh nobody knew anything
you know I had I didn't tell anybody
just you know my wife and uh
and I was off
uh
when I came to the states I already kind
of dabbled in the whole training field
and showing
some of my experience to people so I had
at least a seed of that out there people
knew me for that
um
but all of a sudden I was uh
in the middle of an avocado Orchard
uh in the middle of California
and everything's quiet and
there's no more radios going off all
over the night there's some more three
three cell phones on the counter there's
no guns there's no rifles there's no
uh 80 people calling to to calling to
see what's going on there's nothing
that's just quiet
and it's during the time when Trump got
elected so the immigration process that
usually would take
I had most things going for me and my
migration process that would take
at the most a year took two years
so it was
it was not a it's not an easy process to
not only come to the US but uh
you know come to the US with uh with
that pressure kind of underlying
pressure as far as being an immigrant at
that time here
and then your own personal psychological
the PTSD of of going from a war zone to
a uh avocado Orchard
the word PTSD and TBI and all of these
things I did not I didn't know any of
them uh
it was through people that I got to meet
uh in the training field that were you
know Marines uh
seals uh Marisol guys those types of
people that started giving words to some
of the things that I felt which I didn't
really know you know uh we would treat
uh post-traumatic stress with alcohol
and vacation time yeah
[Music]
yeah when you see the bottom of it your
troubles are gone cured yeah immediately
that was if I was an alcoholic as well
as all the other stuff I was
I was drinking myself to sleep every
every third night uh
my marriage obviously was failing you
know it was
it wasn't easy for her you know she
she was Brave and she did what she could
and I I totally respect to understand
her process with it but
and when it's quiet that's when it hits
you
that's what I think that's what a lot of
people experience when they come back
from a conflict Zone you know the uh
everything that was life and death
everything that mattered all the noise
all the chaos all the people that are
around you that would die for you kill
for you you would kill for them
uh all these millions of dollars worth
of equipment and stuff like that you're
responsible for now are all gone and
it's just you uh walking into a Circle K
and buying three cans of Fosters to
drink yourself to sleep
yeah you write on your patreon
brilliantly
about BTSD about the cost of things
you've done and seen
quote when it's over
and we're far from that chaos and noise
of death being close and life being real
that is when some of us remember in the
quiet nights in a field in Tennessee
looking at fireflies walking through a
fair
holding hands with a lover asking you
what's wrong
and your kid's birthday party leave
early to avoid the ending of a
celebration
that is what the quiet means to some of
us
so that's speaking to that silence the
quiet
um how do you live with and Thrive with
this newly learned term of PTSD if
anything I would recommend people that
have any of these issues to go to places
where other people have
their issues so you can it's not a
competition but you get to see the scope
of problems in the world and you
sometimes feel kind of lucky as far as
your own like it humbles you yeah it
makes you appreciate of all the
different kinds of struggles that people
go through yeah I mean I went through
some portals yet but there's some people
there that went through while they're
more horrible [ __ ] or stuff that I I
don't think I could have survived when I
went through that process of figuring
things out you know the first thing that
glaringly pointed out or stuck out to me
was my inability to
process things like that there was a big
pause button there a giant one
everything was on pause
my reeving not only my mom but my
brother
so I had a pause button on me so start
with 13 basically
uh then I got to bury
many of my friends
inform their wives or girlfriends of
what happened
and that all again was paused because uh
he wasn't uh allowed to process
now I spent years without going on
vacation because I was a workaholic
and uh
I found at the core of my issues uh
alcohol
the giant pause button in the form of
alcohol basically I I'll drink my
problems away or specifically I would
it's like uh if you have a mess in your
house you just put a big tarp over it
you know to cover it up and alcohol was
that for me
and it festered more and more as I
not only went through the process of
learning about pcsd going through
therapy but refusing to let that go you
know it's like going through therapy and
seeing what other people's problems were
and
I don't want to you know this is the
only thing I have I'm not you know I'm
not hurting anybody with it you know why
why am I why do I need to get rid of
that
uh by this point I was traveling across
the country and training people and uh
showing some of the experiences that I
had to other people speaking being on
podcasts and having conversations like
the one I'm having with you so speaking
to the skills that you've developed and
in a way basically reliving and
reopening a bunch of [ __ ] for myself
every time I do it
um so it was that was getting triggered
and the way I would manage that was I
would drink you know at the end of the
night after a weekend class somewhere
when I talk about the fireflies and a
field in Tennessee
it was a moment where I was forcing
myself to try and be sober and we did
this medical class out and uh
out in the hills in Tennessee a
beautiful green Place uh beautiful
family there that that hosted us
and it's the first time I ever saw
fireflies so I was like I thought I was
having a hallucinogenic experience when
I say why is there why are why is the
dust glowing you know is what I thought
a friend of mine
is a the veteran he's ran off to the
woods and grabbed one and brought it to
me and showed it to me it's like holy
[ __ ] what is that's a firefly
wow how do they glow I don't know and
he's crush it in his hand and say it's
gone
and I I you know brought me back
immediately to holy [ __ ] you know uh it
kind of like I was off somewhere and I
was back
and I had to go drink
I went through that process of like
going off it getting on it going off
getting off in my marriage
separate
and that was a
another end of the world aspect to to
everything you know you know
I lost my mother I lost uh the job and
then the marriage failed
and it was on me
I
basically went somewhere and did a stock
of everything that was going on
and made a decision to stop drinking
yeah I had a had some bad relationships
after
and I just came to a place where I need
to stop drink he's got into points so
low
it was a decision you arrived at by
yourself
was there some inspiration
or was this just the point is so low
lost so much it was the start of Cobin
so this is recent this is probably too
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna have two
years sober in December
so when you talk to Rogan the first time
you're still struggling with this demon
I was in and out of the car basically
what I would say you know I was in and
out of and then
trying to get rid of it
that must be a super stressful
experience talking to Joe Rogan the
first time do you drink that night
you remember the second time I was there
I would I went somewhere got shit-faced
it was
it was stressful not not for any other
reason than I felt the responsibility to
the people that couldn't speak about it
so that's the pressure
it was the start of covet and things got
it started getting shut down and slowed
down
my dad got really sick and almost died
foreign
level [ __ ] that is at my brother's place
we
he was in Mexico you know so we had to
bribe a guy to get us an oxygen tank and
I had to Jimmy Reagan a respirator and
it was it was it was it was some [ __ ]
but my dad was like
you know he really survived it you know
everybody at the doctors were like say
goodbye
and the the my dad was like yeah say
goodbye to him you know
okay so your dad's a gangster I got it
a tough guy he did some gangster [ __ ]
that day
but uh on my end I was being isolated
basically his covet is uh everybody's
slowing down no more classes no more
excuses to go out there and drink and no
more socializing so social drinking
turned into alone drinking more and more
and more
I bought a bottle of gin
because uh I was I was down in Mexico
taking care of my dad
and uh they closed down beer production
in Mexico
so beer went away
and beer was a way I kind of Managed IT
you know it's not powered alcohol it's
just beer so you know
but that went away so it was just hard
alcohol that was available down there
I uh
one night alone at the uh at the house
my dad's house I uh
I drank a bottle of gin a whole bottle
of
I almost died
and after that you know
some people started noticing that uh
that I was isolating more and more and
it was kind of eating away at me
I was in a relationship at that point
when I
I started seeing everything just kind of
fall apart around me
and
I I drank half of a glass of uh wine
and it made me sick to my like
internally in my mind
and uh my kid
said uh to me and I don't know nobody
coached or nobody said anything to her
she was pretty intuitive kid
he said I don't drink anymore dad
I thought of nowhere in the middle of
the night
uh and I stopped
I stopped that and I said I stopped that
night I remember waking up at three in
the morning uh and taking a cooler that
I had and just dumping all the beers in
it and
chucking them in the garbage and with a
knife poking each of them to not you
know be tempted to go pack for them
and then the second day I went around
and started finding the hides that I had
because I had some you know hides yeah
and uh
and then I went somewhere and locked
myself in for
two weeks
uh
I had the
the withdrawals uh
the clearest nightmares that I've ever
had in my life or
two three weeks
I went somewhere and I want to keep them
private but I went somewhere where
they offered a place for me and uh
when I asked him about it it's a
community I gave them some money for
their school as a donation again like a
few a few thousand dollars
as yeah sure come you know you can you
can go through this process here coolest
black people the first thing I they did
when I got there is they stood me up in
front of everybody to thank me for the
donation
and then told everybody that I was an
alcoholic and if anybody saw me drinking
I was to be kicked out of there
immediately
and uh I actually felt horrible
um so
that's that was where I started is that
Temptation still there
there was a moment when it was
uh and
uh some uh therapy Circle
there's a there's a rodeo clown friend
of mine who his body's
his spine is basically fused together
you know type of guy
uh we've been friends and enemies and
friends again you know in during the
heart therapy uh Circle uh sessions oh
so like there's an intimacy there yeah
um he didn't know anything about me
uh at One Time Warner was telling our
story he stood up and told his story
and then he heard mine and then he was
pissed off at me and didn't want to talk
to me for a while
and then later he told me that it was
because yeah he saw what I did with my
experience and how much of a difference
that he perceived that I was making with
it
and he felt uh jealous that he couldn't
do the same with his experience because
he was just a broken Vex rodeo clown
he told me
when I was going through the process
like yeah your internet celebrity person
you know you're known
uh aren't you worried about people
finding out that you're that you're
recovering drunk and I said yeah it's
[ __ ] scary as [ __ ] if people find out
that I am going through this process
it's scary that you know the critique
you know I already get a lot of [ __ ] for
being a ex-police officer in Mexico and
all that uh all the negativity that
comes from that
and he said don't be
you know that you can't pick pocket a
naked man so just get naked and what
does that mean write about it post it
online
you never know somebody somebody out
there might get inspired do their own
kind of process
so I started posting about it
cowardly in a way because I wanted to
make other people keep me on the path
you know
but in other ways you know uh
desperation you know I don't I don't
want to drink anymore I don't want to go
back to that on that uh bathrooms which
I know leads directly to a bad death
I'm not afraid of death I just want a
good one I don't want a bad one I think
that was going to lead me to a bad death
I started writing about and sharing it
online you know through my uh fever
dreams post and
just uh being humorous about it online
and
getting a lot of hate on one side you
know having a few people and companies
that I work with kind of step back and
seeing this guys have some issues to
having other people kind of make fun of
or make light of that uh
weakness portrayed us to getting hate
getting criticism because here you are a
kind of narcotics police officer there's
now has a drinking problem so is that
like supposed to be what like flaws
revealed weakness uh or a perception of
alpha in the US I guess that some people
have you know you were supposed to be
strong and here you are I mean I'm not
I'm not Jocko willnick I'm not David
Goggins you know I'll I'll I wake up at
10 in the morning sometimes and I'll
have corn flakes with my eight-year-old
you know
um I like days off I used to wake up at
3 30 in the morning every day to to
review what happened during the night
and then go off for a jog and then
the gym and just be ready to be able to
murder somebody with my hands if I had
to but that is I couldn't maintain that
during the whole process of getting out
of it now leaving alcohol
I remember just being honest with it and
just seeing the two sides of it you know
Joe told me never read the comment
section right which is a beautiful
it's a beautiful piece of advice but uh
sometimes when you talk about some of
these things openly and some of the
comments were positive and I've been
seeing people comment sending me
messages and meeting people on the road
that are five months in
10 months some people that have been on
that uh
wagon for way longer than I have
and uh
there's it's what's cool when you meet
people that are superhuman or
perform and uh take an extreme ownership
of things and are just amazing people
that are you know thriving out there
that it's inspirational I see some of
these people and I'm like holy [ __ ] I
need to figure out how to get to some
symbols of that but I'm not that you
know I've been through the ringer I
[ __ ] up I shed ton of times you know
my nose is a example of that and
a few missing teeth
but in a way I think all of that is
part of the process that not a lot of
people want to talk about you know
independently of the experience I got
down there and some of the things that I
show and talk about and some of the
advocacy I do related to women like her
that are you know trying to look for a
better life and trying to find their
missing kids
uh training people to not get into those
situations uh but also showcasing the
fact that people that go through some of
these processes have
a journey to go through you know uh
I just came into your studio with a
duffel bag straight from the airport and
I'm gonna leave uh early tomorrow
morning to somewhere else
I've been on the road for
almost I think five years Non-Stop
I go back to a specific place every week
to see my kid for two three days and
then I'm back out
you know you know some people like are
you running like are you worried this is
afraid about so no but I am you know on
this weird
path I guess trying to look for
something that I think of
been missing
as far as my afterlife of A Sort you
know coming up that is are you looking
for some kind of a deep understanding of
humanity like from the specific
experiences you had to get some deeper
understanding of what the hell we're all
doing here I meet people every weekend
with different stories uh you know
people come to some of my classes I know
I show them how to weaponize the
environment how to arm themselves how to
not get abducted I meet people that have
gone through those experience and then
are basically trying to work through
some of their own issues by going
through the training like that
I get to meet people that are you know
people that I've only seen online you
know or the scene in videos I I remember
meeting Royce Gracie in uh Harbor City I
heard of that guy he's a pretty
interesting character I remember seeing
him in a bootleg VHS video and I told
him about it uh we were doing a class uh
out at uh
uh Emerson knives it's a it's a it's a
Knife Company but the but Mr Emerson
also has like a Jiu Jitsu gym there
where Royce trades out of that's his uh
that's his space
and you know they're teaching how to
defend against somebody trying to stab
you and I'm showing them all the ways
you can get around that and fabricate
and improvise and smuggle things
basically the the adversarial side of
that it's just that's what I'm known for
the psychology and kind of the ways that
people do that and
I remember him seeing some of the stuff
that I was doing and just being like
where are you from Mexico
makes sense you know somebody from
Brazil you know tipping the hat to
somebody from Mexico as far as with him
uh seeing the violence and some of the
uh the mentality behind it so for people
who don't know who is Gracie is the
legendary martial artist that probably
introduced Brazilian Jiu Jitsu to the
American Audio to the world through the
process of UFC and showing the
effectiveness of it and um
in practice that a little skinny guy can
defeat a big aggressive guy so an
anaconda a small Anaconda walking into
that uh ring with his family behind
wearing pajamas wearing pajamas and
everybody what is this guy wearing
pajamas for and then he would strangle
people with those pajamas uh I remember
seeing that and just having it I think
probably what a generation before had
with Bruce Lee I guess or my generation
was Royce walking into that uh
walking into that octagon and changing
you know paradigms
seeing him in that gym
it's also I have a gun owner and shooter
which is interesting you know having
seeing somebody like him who is
you know well versed with his hands also
be a man that has gone into the realm of
being well versed with with weaponry
which is an aspect of of martial arts
and uh the Marshall way of thinking that
you know some people kind of
the purest will stick with one aside of
it but he's obviously a warrior in a lot
of ways so just a small tangent so
you're somebody that
you don't just look at unarmed combat
you look at the full spectrum of the the
chaos of combat that's outside of the
realm of Jiu Jitsu and even just mixed
martial arts unarmed armed with knives
and Beyond yes was his mind open to the
the Fuller spectrum of violence yeah I
mean he was he was in the middle of this
class that we were doing where people
were basically focusing on both
Ernest Emerson who's a famous for his
knives he's that's a nice company he's
done knives for NASA you know not only
that but he's also a very Avid martial
artist he trained with a lot of Filipino
martial arts related to knives and stuff
like that like but a different mindset
you know a defensive mindset ton of
train people how to defend against that
and you have Royce who's uh he's from
Brazil I mean he has some Street in him
that's something that you know those
guys
we say in Mexico
uh seeing the ways he would uh he
stepped in there and and provided some
encouragement to the people there as far
as uh you know how people sometimes
focus on the uh
this is a system and this is a way but
there's other ways out there that might
negate or defeat the ways that you are
concentrating on you know
so kind of get out of that bubble my
whole kind of specialty or what I focus
on is mindset and figuring out the
software that some of these people gain
and gather from
if I need to arm myself you know the
easiest thing to manufacture in most
places is a pointed object so I can take
that Crystal big pen that you're writing
on that notepad with and using the
friction from the carpet I can turn it
into a hypodermic needle that you can
then poke into somebody's neck what's
the process of doing that so I can do it
right now if you want no but can you can
you use your words for The Listener and
also because I'm terrified I know I
could basically you can take the
friction the the Heat and friction
created from this carpet yes you can
grab that pen in and of itself it will
pierce flesh but it will slow itself
down because it has a few uh angles on
to the on the tip oh you want to wear
down the angles so if you take that tip
off and you grab it and grind it on an
angle on the carpet the heat will
actually turn it into a hypodermic
needle if you know what you're doing I
have a dermic meaning like it's it
smoothens the entry it'll make a point
and an angle that will guide its way
into your flesh so you can actually go
through a torso with that if you know
what you're doing
as a small tangent you also gave me a
present
could be one of the most epic presents
I've ever received you you give it to
Rogan uh can you explain what I'm
holding in my hands there's a guy online
coffin [ __ ] this is a moniker uh it is
a
G10 Rod G10 is a very strong material
basically capable a lot of people make
actually G10 knives which are basically
non-magnetic non-ferrous objects that
can be utilized as a stabbing implement
uh the core of it isn't uh isn't an
actual pencil core it's a G10 core and
it's uh encased in uh Oak hard Oak
so that is capable again of stabbing
through a torso now the guy that made
that uh is an Hardison you know it makes
that it looks like a pencil it's
concealed in in the nature of the object
itself
but that small object is capable of
being introduced into a chest cavity
um you know all it takes is about the
half of your thumb or the length of your
thumb to stab into your chest cavity and
now your pericardium is pierced then
it's being full with filled with blood
or your whole heart is pierced and you
have a few minutes to live if you're at
a standing heart rate so this is uh this
this has the effectiveness of a knife
essentially it has an effectiveness of a
shank or or or an ice pick you know it's
not going to cut but it's going to make
a whole word not the shouldn't be here
the the pen is literally mightier than
the sword yeah well it's uh
this is really epic for me like a
perspective of an academic
this is this is a symbol of both
intelligence and violence I love it and
also the the current state of affairs
where people need to arm themselves with
things that are concealed as far as
their purpose in a place where in a
country or in a society that limits
their ability to arm themselves
so if you're going to a safe place
you're going to a place where no weapons
allowed which means a rich a Target Rich
environment if you're a predator
uh that's a sign of rebellion let this
be a signal of everyone should be
terrified when you're around me because
even a pencil can murder you and I
intend to use this and nobody nobody
owns life but anybody that can hold a
frying pan owns death is a quote that I
heard once which is a beautiful one I'm
looking if anyone betrays me this is the
way to go
can you given all your experience in all
the different ways and you think about
martial arts and violence
in Mexico in the in the world speaking
of hoys
what is your approach to conflict uh
like a like a street fight what advice
would you give people in the full
spectrum of what a street altercation
might entail
what is the best way to approach it I
think before you get there you have to
prepare you know so like one of the
first things I tell people is uh if you
don't have a basic T Triple C training
class behind you you should re-analyze
your your life and your ability to
prepare to be Triple C basically how to
stop somebody from bleeding out or dying
from the Stab Wound gunshot wound or any
of those types of wounds uh or an
amputated leg during an ID scenario
anything you would see in a Boston
Marathon Marathon type event or a Vegas
shooting event where people are getting
shot stabbed cut so understand how to
help people how to help yourself
post you you're no good you don't want
to be a you don't want to be a detriment
to the situation you want to be an asset
so build yourself up as an asset for in
a situation like that because you might
be doing that on yourself or on somebody
else and also it helps you understand uh
what situations are going to result in a
lot of
in a difficult situation to deal with
afterwards yeah it also teaches you what
to stab and what to shoot if you're
thinking about it in a full and on all
the dimensions of it you know you know
there's there's all weapon all knowledge
can be weaponized and I think that's the
approach to all people should kind of
figure out for themselves when they
start getting ready or if they want to
take the responsibility of their own
safety in their hands so in a
self-defense situation there's a lot of
questions here but what what does one
stab
foreign
arteries which are used commonly in Jiu
Jitsu as something to choke because they
feed a computer you know so there's a
lot of blood flowing through that
required for the successful operation of
the computer and not a lot of stuff is
guarding the outside world from your
carotid arteries that's a really weird
design by the way it is not a smart one
it doesn't even make sense because with
mammals they bite each other's and act
like why can't you have more
protection because this is the only like
us humans don't use their mouth to kill
each other but most mammals most
predators do it's like why the hell
don't we protect this we do have a
defensive mechanism and you you see it
sometimes when people are ambushed and
people try to open up each other's necks
from behind
if you push somebody's neck forward the
carotids will actually lower themselves
and be encased in more flesh and muscle
if you pull a head back not so much so
that's a way that at least I think the
evolutionary we've have a defensive
mechanism for that uh there's a few
videos out there of people's getting
their neck sewn back shut after somebody
pushed their head forward to try and
slice their necks and they survived you
know
um so this is a viable Target uh the
heart is another one interesting about
the thing about the heart and people get
alarmed when I talk about this and show
it in classes
uh again a lot of the classes I do are
for orientation and to for people to
recognize that behavior so a lot of law
enforcement comes to some of these
classes though oh that's horrible
that's how somebody will kill somebody
yeah this is how people that know their
thing their [ __ ] will try and approach
somebody and stab you to death This Is
How They would do it
uh there's a tendency to
view what we see in John Wick or view
what we see in uh this martial arts
Community where they're you know slicing
and dicing people different myriadders
of ways
a lot of that is based on dueling based
cultures like the Filipino martial arts
or some of the Italian martial arts out
there where somebody's facing off with
somebody else with a similar weapon
where both of us are agreeing to
basically get into a stabbing
competition
that would make sense in that scenario
in that context but I've never seen a
lot of people actually get into these
one-on-one knife altercations
um what we see now in a modern context
when it talks about weaponry
is an ambush counter Ambush based
scenario where somebody pulls out a
knife turning a grappling situation on
the street or when somebody turns a
striking exchange of punches it punches
into pulling out a cheap gas station
knife or
a pen or a rock from the ground or a
handgun most modern combatives when it
comes to Weaponry should be kind of
based on the whole aspect of Ambush
encounter Ambush there's a lot of people
showing uh valuable kind of material and
coursework on this out there
um my whole approach and my specific
kind of Realm is in the aspect of how
people go from the process of learning
some of these things from experiential
stuff people that grow up in rural rural
places grow up on pig farms that
actually get the experiences of
processing the pig for example or
processing an animal those people will
have more skills Hunters those people
will have more skills with a knife if
they pick it up as a weapon then
most of the martial artists that I've
seen kind of approach some of these uh
classes where I go and have a simulated
torso in the form of a pig hanging in a
room somewhere
some of that has to do with just the
the familiarity and the comfort of just
like the biology of a living organism
like that you if you cut off certain
things if you cut a certain thing like
it's [ __ ] it's just a meat vehicle the
same thing you know the medical training
should come first you know or if you
don't have that be a hunter or go to a a
Butchery class that will teach you more
about how to use a knife
on somebody else than anything you know
that'll that'll give you the experience
of Flesh uh most people you know I do
this example every now and then where I
have people bring in a
a tactical knife and they'll bring in a
butter knife and I asked them which will
go through a torso we have a pig there
so it simulates a torso pretty closely
most people will say ah that butter
knife's not going to go through and it
does you know it does go through it's a
thin enough strong enough sturdy enough
that'll go through
um kitchen knife
a cheap one that cost 89 cents at uh at
a Walmart and a expensive 400 one yeah
and the the cheap one will outperform
the expensive ones the tip will snap off
uh during some of it
yeah I have to say that it just is a
small uh tangent I went to farm
and uh just seeing the butchering of
meat and so on uh in the processing of
me and pigs and cows
that's uncomfortable yeah but I think it
also it's honest and raw and like that's
something that probably everyone should
experience regularly uh
because it it's also humbling to remind
you like when I um
I had a dog Homer he's in Newfoundland
that was I was very close with and uh we
lost them and I I just remember that
carried him he's like 200 something
pounds and it said to carry him I had to
put him to sleep and like one of the
biggest realizations is like oh this is
just a
this is just a biological thing yeah
it's just and then to to realize that
this is just meat
this is not and you can cut it
and then you if you bleed you all sudden
the life can disappear from you yeah and
it's all gone it's like holy [ __ ]
there's this meat vehicle that some
people have referred to as Lex
is I'm just a few stabbings away from
like leaving yeah I'm leaving goodbye
that's a soul that just flies away yeah
it used to be that we had to hang around
you know people would come back from
battling we would hear things next to
the campfire
as far as oh he stab somebody here and
this happens but now we live in an age
where you can you know when I do a class
I this is this is a stab to the heart
and here's like five videos of it
happening live you know on live leaks or
whatever and we can deconstruct that not
only that but what weapon was used oh it
was a gas station folder it was a
Pioneer Woman knife from Walmart with
flowers on the handle you know whatever
it was uh and people start realizing
that it doesn't take a lot
that it doesn't take a lot of training
because a lot of these people are not
high level assassins trained by ninjas
in the Hills or anything like that there
are people that you know grew up rurally
or learned by seeing that behavior in
others
and when they start coming to the
realization that it's pretty easy to do
that and they start figuring out like
how do you counteract that well number
one learn the behavior yourself so you
can recognize it the whole aspect of
being a good counter Ambush team is to
be a best the best ambusher in the
planet
so again the whole aspect of Musashi
saying know your enemy know his sword
you know you figure that out as far as
learning that behavior
you know when you start seeing how some
of these stabbings occurred occur the
first thing you notice is that one of
one of the hands is always kind of out
of the picture or there's a lack of
symmetry in the people that are about to
do something horrible
so when you see lack of symmetry in the
environment somebody with their hands
going backwards
um there's a crowd of people and some
and and two or one individual is looking
counter where everybody else is looking
or there's a hyper-aware individual in
the crowd uh the hyper aware are always
usually out there to [ __ ] somebody over
or are there trying to keep those
Predators from plucking somebody else
over so
unless you step back and you put
yourself in the process of learning how
they learn and you become that potential
nightmare person it's hard to recognize
that in a crowd it feels like one of the
significant ways to win or as a street
fighter is to avoided by sort of sending
pacifist signals in every way meaning
avoiding the situation whenever there's
like uh like a hyper Vigilant people you
just kind of avoid signaling that you're
one of the players of Interest yeah if
we're talking about counter Ambush at
which point do you do that versus shift
to the
aggression yeah I think violence should
be always an option you know everybody
should have that option and you need to
be good at that option I think uh I
think I heard Jordan Peterson talk about
the fact that everybody needs to be
dangerous but keep that [ __ ] under
control you know yeah I think he was
referring to a different context but I
don't know I know I'm referring to the
ability of the little physical conflict
uh there's two cases that I saw of
people just utilizing social engineering
to a beautiful degree to de-escalate
[ __ ] right one guy uh somewhere first
off if you're in a place where people
are grabbing your wife's ass or
something like that like what are you
doing there you know there's a load of
things that are wrong with everything
that you're doing in your life to be in
that environment but yeah let's say
you're in an inescapable situation
there was this guy who was in a
compromised position uh somebody wanted
to fight him uh like legit kick his ass
and he said okay uh I'm let's go but I I
just I need to warn you that I have
Pepsi before we go outside
and that is masterful I was getting my
phone out to to film this you know maybe
uh and even I was just lowered my phone
to give him a slow clap that was a
beautiful move you know
um and then there was this other man uh
there was a there was a riot somewhere
in uh in Ensenada the municipality went
in Baja they were protesting some of the
people that picked those fields down
there part of a tribe called Los trigis
very Hardy hard-working people but
nefarious people too they're they're
pretty they're pretty good at their
thing
um
there was a right line they couldn't
break
and this old man walks in the middle of
the right line and yells grenade and
throws an avocado in the middle of all
the cops and I'm like
you broke that rye line with an avocado
that could have gone wrong in so many
ways but it didn't I don't know to me
it's like it's there's a small lessons
there there is a case to be made about
social engineering about learning about
Behavior but learning how to lie and how
to kind of move your way or navigate
your way around situations like that
small things like bartering knowing how
to bribe people in Conflict zones is the
thing that I I show when I talk about or
train people to work in hospital
environments
de-escalation you know is specifically
kind of figuring out what is a value in
the environment what things you
shouldn't be doing in an environment
that might be considered disrespectful
or out of place you know people have a
tendency that that didn't grow up in
places that are violent to make
continuous eye contact with somebody
maybe that might be a issue
or smiling when there's nothing to smile
about I think you know uh there's a
picture I saw somewhere of Russians
taking a a portrait and there's
Americans there and the Americans are
smiling but the Russians aren't yeah
because what is there to smile about
which is true and of course it's not as
simple a smile or not smile there's
subtlety to it like you said eye contact
this is a super interesting one because
um
I found in my in my own life like not
making eye contact is
other people would be joking but it's a
really powerful way to de-escalate and
there's such a fascinating thing though
because you could talk about drunk
fights that are just
uh that are harmless but I feel like the
same Dynamic applies to the most violent
conflict including Wars I feel like ego
is part of this so to me the question of
conflict whether it's a street fight or
anything else
is the calculus of are you willing to
taken out
uh in terms of psychology somebody grabs
your wife's ass you mentioned
boy if you let that happen you go home
you don't have to pay the price of you
were the person who didn't Define you
like in your relationship yeah you
didn't defend your wife's honor yeah
you're gonna psychologically pay that
price yourself and
depending on your wife she might
secretly also lose a little bit of
respect for you yeah now how do you play
that calculus because now we see the war
in Ukraine
I would say there is elements of similar
posturing in the United States in in
Europe in in Ukraine Russia China
leadership
at a geopolitics it's still somebody
grabs somebody's ass
and you're not backing down so to take
those losses and basically just posture
you know lower your head and live to
fight another day type that situation
the thing with modern violence is you
know
the access to Weaponry uh you know and I
mean again nobody owns life but anybody
can hold a frying pan can own death I've
seen people
um you know get double leg take down
somebody on the ground it's a different
thing doing the mats versus concrete
that's a good way to kill somebody you
know the the most prolific impact weapon
on the planet is the planet itself you
can see various videos of people online
where they fall and they hit their head
or somebody hit their head and they go
into you know the stretched out fit
basically uh and that might not kill you
then but it'll kill you that night or
the second night if you don't get
checked out you know people bleed out
internally get an edema again the whole
aspect of me showing how some of these
things
not only some of these methodologies and
somehow people prepare for violence and
how people experience violence how they
make their weapons how the people fight
in the streets and stuff like that
is to recognize that behavior from the
Inception you know uh there's a video I
show where there's a bunch of Street
kids in Rio de Janeiro I think it's
during the Olympics where they're
snatching Jane's and cell phones from
people and it's a fun video you know see
it and it's uh the first thing you learn
about it is how they Target people
now who are they going after there's a
bunch of people there why are they going
after that specific person
and you start learning about profiling
and how they identify victim mentality
you know or the Vic the perfect victim
you know lack of awareness
they keep on a straight line avoidance
avoidance of eye contact if they're you
know doing something the fairies are
wrong uh and how they pick who they're
going to go after you know the small
people the the women you know the the
even some of the men
and they separate the men that they're
perfect victims versus the men that's
going to turn around punch them in the
face you know what are they looking for
you know
well first off you know you notice that
the the men that are in that environment
that look at them and are aware of their
presence the hyper aware are the ones
that are not a good to Target so that's
the first lesson there so probably a
good idea not only to be hyper aware but
to recognize that hyper awareness than
others if I want to separate myself from
the victim crap
another thing you notice is these are
kids going after some grown adults and
some of these grown adult men are with
women
and you see them you know kind of
getting outside of the grasp of the
these kids that are trying to rip their
chains off their neck or their cell
phones and they have no consideration
for the women around them uh you see
other men that are with women and you
see them grab the women and put them
behind them
and immediately they'll say this this is
the wrong one let me move off to the
next one
so that that small little lesson in the
in those videos will show you first how
these kids are growing up Target to
profile and Target who the perfect
victims are that's a school for them
and that is an adversarial school we
should look at that school and apply to
ourselves so in general you think
conflict ultimately the people that are
doing conflict they're looking for for
weakness I mean they're looking for
opportunity opportunistic that's the
Predators that's what they do they look
for an opportunity you know uh from
jumping down from a tree and and getting
the slowest gazelle to
uh looking for the opportune moment to
pounce on something that's probably big
but the risk is worth it I feel like
there's uh several motivations but but
isn't isn't there also
her power hierarchy motivation as well
yeah like you there's something about
the big guy that tempts you to send a
message especially with gangs aren't
they sent aren't they constantly uh sort
of trying to signal that they're the
alpha yeah I mean there's I mean there's
a different situation so you could be
you could be facing a sociopathic
Predator who is looking for something in
you that you were the resource that
they're looking after
maybe it's a woman you know it could be
a group of people that don't like the
fact that you have a specific uh
nationality uh or your passport is
stamped in a specific way or that you
pray to whatever God
all these factor in
uh but in the end they all do the same
thing they look for an advantageous
position if I were to Target you I would
put you in between that wall and you
know me so you have two Avenues of exits
and I will step on one of your feet to
keep that Avenue closed so you have to
go this way so this is where my knife is
going to be you see that behavior
mirrored everywhere in the world first
off you look for advantages right if
it's something that's unavoidable like
you're in between me and my ability to
go home or you're in between me and my
ability to feed my family or you're in
between me and my ability to posture to
the people that are behind me the young
guys that I'm in charge
I will do everything in my power
to end you right
the motivations are
not my Realm
but the ways they do it are are you know
and basically the advantage part of it
so desperation is uh
is dangerous
it's a dangerous school when I say
dangerous school I mean the most
dangerous people usually come from those
desperate environments you know you can
have uh people in Coronado holding on to
logs in the ocean and going through this
millions of dollars worth of training
and just be professional Killers for the
government and just be these incredible
human beings
and then there's a kid that will walk up
to one of them when he's off you know
and put an ice pick right into his chest
uh when he's least expecting it and that
doesn't mean that one is superior than
the other it just means that there are
more that there's more than one way to
become that you know teenagers terrify
me it feels like the intensity of
desperation
like the capacity of a teenager
like 16 17 to be desperate and also not
have the matured understanding of ethics
of the world like they have this
intensity of feeling
uh that I wasn't like anything else they
don't have a volume knob to that yeah so
it's like uh it's like a garden hose
without a nozzle on it so you can
regulate it they haven't developed that
they haven't learned that maybe from
somebody else or it used to be Warrior
cultures you would you would Apprentice
under somebody or you would learn some
of these things from other people even
some gang modern gangs have a little bit
of that
but if you're not and you're just this
kid that's been playing Call of Duty uh
all of his life or that has been
witnessing violence and media and
there's no
sense of
it's probably a bad idea to go off and
do this because all these repercussions
I could see how that could be uh danger
to society and some of the volume knobs
some of the
countermeasures the people exploding on
somebody else with a well
with a weapon you know that you see
videos constantly online I remember
seeing this one of these two uh
teenage girls somewhere in the US and
one of them just
there's a fight there's a hair pulling
competition and all of a sudden one of
them takes out a knife
and it just happens like that and
it's just pure and restrained
downward styling now
you're like wait where's that come from
well uh she's from an environment where
she saw that as an option
she didn't see the repercussions of it
and she found herself in a place where
she thought that was the only viable
option pulling out a weapon
that's I think that's that's the
dangerous part of it so how do you
prepare to win those kinds of situations
just keep those kinds of situations
like you said this training it's
exposing your mind I always tell people
like if you don't have a combative base
you don't have a base
uh boxing Jiu Jitsu and that that gives
you what like an awareness of your body
kind of thing it gives you an awareness
of your body you give you a spatial
awareness if somebody if you if you
can't see the points with your
peripheral vision if you can't see the
points of somebody's feet in your
peripheral vision they are in range to
stab you in the heart if they wanted to
and that's something you learn from
boxing that you learn from Jiu Jitsu you
learn from a bunch of combat Arts where
you you learn about distance and angling
people
that comes from this experience that you
have you know again a lot of these
things were just a horse play when we
were growing up in some cultures or you
know Rough and Tumble with your brothers
and [ __ ] like that but we're some of us
are growing up in single kid homes now
and we don't get that we're missing that
and if you don't have it then you find
it in the
you find it in a Jiu Jitsu gym you find
it in a boxing gym you have it you find
it a Thai boxing gym you find it in
places where they specialize in
focusing on certain aspects of this
whole combative hole right it used to be
before UFC you know the Kung Fu man you
know that Kung Fu guy that's just Street
Lethal [ __ ] you yeah you can't use it in
the sporting car you can't show you this
because it'll kill you now we pretty
much know that most of that was
you know Flights of Fancy or BS you know
it pains me too man I wanted to learn
some of the dmac single punching and
killing technique you know I remember
those books but that's just not still on
the lookout for that maybe somewhere I
don't know you know maybe if you put a
pen in your hand that that might turn
into that but yes that's the only way
that's the only way right but uh
a lot of these myths are kind of like
faded away and now you see people that
have different combative bases combining
them all and becoming a fighter now
that's the UFC fight two people fighting
each other's one thing you know you
being in the middle of the Portland
rides and a bunch of state troopers
throwing gas at rioters and then Riders
themselves fighting each other and you
finding yourself in the middle of that
that's a completely different thing
and if you think you're gonna you know
go on go on the ground and get in a
guard with a with a with a guy swinging
around a shovel a piece of a shovel
handle right as tear gas is going on
because you got uh stop there and your
car was you know windows were broken and
your family's in the back seat
you know that is a different situation
so
you know I'm getting medical uh
learning how learning about Weaponry you
know uh I I personally don't really like
fighting on the ground
but that's why I forced myself to go to
the train with different people out
there you know uh the on the ground Jiu
Jitsu cash wrestling to top and bottom
neither you don't like either personally
I like being in a car and running
everybody over that would be great you
know if I could or driving really far
away or uh
I had this I had this experience in Utah
uh some some friends of mine a military
uh some of your best Shooters the some
of the best years in the US you know
coming from the uh the Marine Corps
we're showing you were showing me how
they you know would shoot something from
really far away
and I was like oh
you don't even have to be in the same
vicinity
the scope of violence and how far you
can be from it or how close you could be
from it just wait till we get to see
what we can do in the Cyber attack world
we can destroy your whole well-being
your whole life your identity that's
another aspect of it too financial and
then uh figure out where you live in
terms of Ambush yeah figuring out
everything about you such that hurting
you is easy I have a class where we
specifically work on social engineering
and kind of
how how you can go about something that
you know on a micro level uh we I do a
class with a guy named Matt Fiddler who
does uh basically he's one of the
Premier experts on how to get into and
bypass locks basically
yeah you'll we he'll show you how to
open up every single bypass every single
commercial lock available in the United
States like he'll spread it out to open
up everything and that's like
right and my part in his class is I talk
about how you can pull some of that off
in a public space and not get caught or
how you would employ some of these
things in a context where it's useful
for law enforcement for the military
stuff like that
and uh so we have this exercise in a
public space where there's a bunch of
padlocks in the environment right and
they paint them pink so people know it's
our padlocks and we're not breaking into
anybody else's padlocks if we get
approached and asked about it
but I asked the students like so you
have to gather all these padlocks from
this public space you know so how would
you do it so a lot of them are trying to
pick them you know they're like it's
very suspiciously picking them and stuff
like that that you get caught and it's a
whole situation
but the Smart Ones Will basically
develop a social media campaign related
to the bat box right
a beautiful a beautiful example of this
and this actually happened here in Texas
I did a class out in Dallas we put the
padlocks all over this public mall
and the students basically came up with
a breast cancer awareness campaign
online that they they made fake uh well
they made flyers for it they did the
social media page on a campaign
they did this email chain so when they
went there people were expecting them so
they normalized the behavior through
social media and they were walking
around bolt cutters in the middle of the
mall cutting these things off
that's a beautiful yeah that's a
beautiful solution to a complex problem
that nature and again what the
weaponizing part of it anything could be
all knowledge could be weaponized and
it's if you focus on getting in a street
fight with somebody with your fist or a
knife you know you're missing out on the
whole complexity of violence and in the
way that it's now being utilized
so in terms of breaking out locks
and restraints and captivity
let's talk about a dark topic that
you're one of the world experts in
kidnapping so you teach courses on
counter kidnapping and terrorism
I read an estimate that criminal gains
get 500 million dollars a year in Ransom
payments from kidnapping so just at a
high level what is kidnapping who does
it and why what are some insights that
can help
us understand what is this problem in
the world it happens in different ways
in different parts of the world I mean I
just sent off a group of people that
trained some of the ukrainians and some
of the stuff that they were show they
were showing them was some of the
counter custody stuff that I showed them
a friend of mine named Vince went out
there was showing them some of the
aspects of how to utilize things like
Kevlar cordage and how to infuse it in
their uniform so if they get uh zip tied
to cut them open it's a war setting so
it talks about being captive in a war
zone but the information or the
methodology actually comes from Mexico
that methodology as far as how I learned
it in terms of how to escape from
strange yeah so in Mexico you have
abductions happening where uh cartels uh
who hold uh control over a specific
place or Zone
um are having a hard time uh with
financial situations as far as uh maybe
they're not making enough money to pay
everybody off so they let them freelance
basically and a lot of ways some of
these criminal groups freelance or some
of these groups actually professionalize
in to abduct businessmen abduct the sons
of businessmen or people that have money
to ask for ransoms for them basically
and uh they've taken
you know captivity and abduction to like
an art form in places like Mexico and
has a history all over the world but uh
specifically my experience with it with
it was going to
uh cartel safe houses that turned into
holding places you would see you know
homemade prison cells and stuff like
that and people being held in captivity
for months if not years
as they were milking their family for
everything they owned so it turns out
into a business they're not actually
even interested in hurting the people
physically they're interested in hurting
them
uh financially financially and also this
if they get hurt they're hurt for a
purpose which is to make their family
pay up faster or more uh some of the
abduction groups that I've seen out
there professional ones in Mexico
basically make it a living to Target
people that have abduction insurance or
that work for companies that have good
abduction insurance so it's it's almost
like an ATM for them you know it's like
ah hero again huh so there's some of
that going on uh some not so much some
abductions are expressed I mean I'll
grab you with a and gunpoint take you to
an ATM you empty it out and then you're
on your way that's an Express kidnapping
that might not be worth you doing
anything insane you know you just go
with the motions
um but some people do get picked up you
know uh I have trained people with prior
experiences of abductions in Mexico and
here in the United States people that
have spent some time in captivity with
loved ones here like ex-boyfriends or
boyfriends that tie them up and beat the
[ __ ] out of them
and the restraints that utilize are zip
ties and handcuffs sometimes or duct
tape or their own clothing things of
this nature basically what somebody's
looking for when they tie anybody up is
to convince you that they are in control
that they are God and that any hope of
you releasing the restraints or getting
out of that situation is hopeless
from a cartel group picking you up in
the middle of uh dirt road somewhere in
Cancun to uh ex-boyfriend showing up at
your house and tying you up till you
agree to get back with them that's the
same thing
uh and some of the restraints that are
being utilized come from different
places I mean I remember as an
instructor I had way back when told me
that the proliferation of zip ties is a
restraint in criminal abductions came up
after the movie Heat came out because
everybody wanted to be Robert De Niro
zip dying people in the bank robbery at
the end of the movie
criminal saw that and it became like
hilarious can you actually speak to the
is it possible to systematically learn
how to escape restraints like handcuffs
rope zip ties the best at it or not the
military they're not see your program
people they are criminals I learned how
to get a handcuffs from a 15 year old
who was in charge of meth sales and and
uh revolution in Tijuana is there a
system to it I mean it's not
specifically a system it's uh usually
what they what happens is they'll buy a
set of handcuffs and they will mess
around with them in a playing feature so
one thing I do in a class is first off
I'm honest about the fact that some you
know all the restraints are temporary
even marriage
this is this is like wait can we just
pause on the Deep philosophical you're
like Yamoto Musashi with that statement
all all restraints are temporary even
marriage uh I'll just uh just I just
like adding that one in there for last
because this is a dark subject every
cage can be escaped all restraints are
temporary you you either free yourself
from the restraints somebody else takes
them off or you die and your body rots
your way around them you know those are
the options
um and I like that first option myself
the second option is pretty cool if you
can convince somebody to do that for you
but that first option is an interesting
one
you have to deconstruct restraints not
all restraints are made the same uh you
can train to get out of handcuffs here
in the US and you know focus on the
Paris Smith and Western handcuffs which
are kind of the most common brand of
handcuffs here
but if you find yourself in detention
somewhere in Russia the handcuffs out
there are completely different you know
the key way is different the mechanism
is different but some of the same ways
of bypassing those mechanisms all right
it's down so in Russia what kind are
they using they're traveling there they
need this information I'll send you a
specific model and details on how to get
out of those uh but basically asking for
a friend I'm sorry so what I do is I I
take I take a pair of Smith and Wesson
handcuffs I put them in the middle of uh
three people in the in a class I spread
them out and I have them place them on
each other in a just playing manner I
have Hank I have handcuffed Keith there
and I have a pair of bolt cutters there
in case somebody gets stuck that's
something stupid
so they they play with each other as far
as putting them on randomly I show them
how to put them on appropriately and
then I show them a handcuff key and a
handcuff key will open up handcuffs
interestingly enough
but the thing about a handcuff key is
it's not made to be used by the person
that is in those handcuffs
so that's the first lesson there
if you have a hank of key handcuff keys
are the most used tool to open up
handcuffs in custody situations you know
both criminals escape from the police to
people escaping from criminals just a
standard hidden handcuff key so I show
them how to modify the Handcuff key so
it's more optimal to use on yourself
with just basic garbage that you can
find piece of wire a zip type piece
basically how to put a leverage arm on
the Handcuff key so you can actually
spin it in the key way behind your back
or in front of you
I'm trying to think I don't think I've
ever been in handcuffed
appropriate way to handcuff somebody's
Palms out how much restriction is there
in terms of there's a lot if it's a it's
a hinge handcuff there's a lot of
restriction
can you reach back you could try and
reach back or you can basically put
yourself in a not compromised position
and
feed the most of your palm meat into the
Handcuff way so when they shut it shut
it on you you have more space to work
with so you can spin your hand we call
it a passive resistance again you go
through a process within where you
deconstruct how people are handcuffed
handcuff keys and how to modify hand
cookie to be able to use on yourself and
these all of these things they're
constructing as we go
so they basically hey what's a grinding
surface well there's concrete outside so
they grind and angle on the key so you
can get a key not to go straight into
the keyway but you can get it into the
keyway at an angle for example it's
something it's something that is out
there as far as a method you can't spin
a key behind your back because it's
small it's designed to be used by
somebody else opening those handcuffs on
you so you put an arm on it so you can
leverage our arm so you can spin it
behind your back
you learn how to put yourself in not a
compromised position if somebody asks
you for your hand cut or your hands so
they could be cuffed you don't do this
you know you do that or you put yourself
in a cable grip behind your back which
is a pretty strong grip and it's hard to
spread those hands apart it's also
something that people go into
automatically when they're in fear so
all these things are advantageous for
you
and you learn how not only people get
restrained but you see videos of them
because I show a bunch of abduction
that's actually happening live
again the best thing is avoidance but
specifically when you work around
restraints is number one learn how some
of these restraints work
number two is learning how some of the
ready-made tools to get out of the
restraints look like function
and number three which is the advanced
level is learn how to construct all
these things yourself which is I think
that is the that is the best thing you
can show somebody
for handcuffs I just use a standard pair
of handcuffs and then we deconstruct
other very specialized handcuffs that
might be out there and you show them if
you're going to travel somewhere learn
what restraints are commonly in the
available in the environment somebody
going to North sub-Saharan Africa
carrying a plastic handcuff key is
that's going to be useless out there
because there's not going to be standard
handcuffs out there that would be
open with that type of key out there
you're probably going to be tied up with
a chain and a padlock of some sort maybe
a 40 millimeter Chinese padlock with a
plastic core that you can open with a
a lighter if you can burn the core melt
the core open or if you can leverage
that open that's a pretty easy thing to
open or a bobby pin you could reach all
the way in the back and open the latch a
little
rope
uh the common yeah it is common uh this
is one of my favorite things for rope
something I usually carry in some places
it's another gift for you if you want
it's a ceramic razor blade nice is it
capable of cutting
nice that small uh you can put it behind
a label I've seen some students put the
Levi's label on there and just sew it
back on
um it is non-magnetic non-ferrous so in
and out of uh you know that type of
situation you can get in and it's
something you can have with you
everywhere
this is a pretty fancy one or you can
just grab a simple razor blade actually
learning how to use or leverage a razor
blade between your palms and
know how to go up and down with it to be
able to cut yourself of course so that's
just practice to do that well it's
practice and it's also exposure to just
this is a possibility this is how you
can hide it again the whole smuggling
aspect comes from a criminal uh criminal
mindset type setting so how how things
are hidden where they're hidden and when
I talk about concealing objects of this
nature it usually comes from
smuggling you know the fact that I have
something in a notebook comes from
heroin smuggling
if you're not looking at the school of
criminality you're missing out on a big
part of the equation
so for people who want to learn about
this do you teach courses on this do you
know what's the right what's the wreck
how do you get in touch with you or
learn from you do you have stuff online
or is it only so I have some stuff on my
patreon uh specifically I have a patreon
where I share a lot of the
online material like basically a bunch
of this is my notebook I have a bunch of
stuff that I I just met somebody in
Philadelphia that showed me a pretty
unique way of utilizing a box cutter as
a weapon so I wrote some of that down I
filmed some of it
um and it's not for any other reason I'm
not trying to create dangerous people
out there it's like hey look at this
this is something that's out there right
um so a lot of that information some of
those notes and stuff like that I keep
on my patreon I used to share it openly
on Facebook and Instagram but that uh
that has not uh been possible anymore
well I'm a member your patreon and
recommend people signing up it's really
great because you also have philosophy
you're you're you're the you're the uh
the Mexican Miyamoto Musashi uh so it's
not just these skills it's also the
philosophy around it like I got that
that book of five rings before I went
into training like I took that with me
through training the whole aspect of you
know go to places uh frightening to the
common brand of men you know be put in
jail and extricate yourself with your
own wisdom I think he was speaking about
experiencing experience you know the
whole Warriors journey of the hero's
journey of going out there and actually
risking
um I think that's a pretty
big basis and aspect of what the work I
do and showing some of these things
there's a tendency to people say hey I'm
afraid to go to Mexico uh what do I need
to know like well if you're afraid to go
to Mexico to go to Mexico I mean I was
in Detroit I was pretty afraid when I
was in Detroit in some parts of Detroit
and uh the South Side Chicago
um but uh
I don't want to be dictated where I can
go and where I can't go because of
safety I want to take responsibility for
that myself and figure out ways of being
more capable and an asset to the people
around me and myself
and that comes from experience
and people don't want to risk getting a
shoulder injury rolling in Jiu Jitsu or
don't want to risk getting a bloody nose
and boxing but that is the way well
there's some aspect to fitting in you
quote hattoria Hanzo an imitation the
most important thing you should keep in
mind when you go on a Shinobi mission is
to imitate well the language is a target
Province and the ways of the local
people this includes their appearances
the way of wearing clothes the way of
shaving their head the way of making up
their hair the way of making up a sword
or short Sword and the way of refinement
and luxury so how do you fit into some
of those places so you know Mexico but
yeah a person like me that doesn't know
anything about Mexico and say I'm
interviewing somebody in a leadership
position at a drug cartel yeah how
quickly do you learn how to fit in I
mean it's not about fitting in it's
about coming up with a narrative for
yourself what that book is talking
that's a that's a quote from the book
called a show linky which is like a an
actual legit ninja manual from like the
1500s or something like that
um and uh they're not talking about
blending in they're talking about
creating a narrative or a lie to your
appearance and your behavior and your
knowledge base that's what they're
talking about so I would say first if
you're going to go to a place like that
first off learn what is common there
what type of common restraints might be
placed on you what criminal groups work
out there what type of guns they have
not only what type of guns they have but
go to the gun range in Vegas and learn
how to fire some of these Firearms
yourself so you know how to load them in
case you run into a bad situation how to
tie the sword you know how they how they
wear their short swords
could equate to how you know
if you run into some issues also it
would give you a good idea how many how
many rounds those hold so you can run at
the right moment I like how you focus in
on the on the tools of violence but
there's also the the social engineering
de-escalation right yeah so if you are
in an environment like that and you are
carrying around the camera that might be
an issue or the opposite it might not be
an issue well if you're asked like who
are you with I'm with the news
organization or am I with a Christian
Aid group here yeah
and if you are with a Christian age
group it's probably a good idea to learn
some of the Bible right if you like if
you want a quick way of having a
somebody out there try and stop talking
to you you can start talking about Jesus
in the middle of a you know a little
cartel territory when they approach you
and take out the Bible that that'll
quickly de-escalate so look at what I
usually prefer to do is I find somebody
from the New York Times And The Wall
Street Journal and beat them up in front
of the sure just to send a signal yeah
journalist and I too don't like
journalists that could that could be
that could be a way but uh to send a
message I think a lot of us miss the
fact that we are capable of taking
control of our own narrative and what we
communicate to people around us I can
show up here uh drinking a Monster
energy drink dumping It On The Ground
scratching you know what then just sit
down and just be a rude [ __ ]
that's not who I am but I can do that
and you will believe me if I am good at
it some of us miss the uh some of us
don't know this aspect because it's
something we consider predatory or
something that is wrong or negative or
bad yeah and some of these aspects are
actually you know know they're pretty
useful
I learned most of my trade craft and
skillcraft from panhandlers and street
performers and when I had some training
related to social engineering those were
the people that I learned from I
remember
we were doing surveillance and there was
a guy there that showed us how to do
surveillance you know on the street and
he said if you can find a way for
somebody to smell you before they see
you
you'll become invisible and I was like
that's [ __ ] if you can find a way of
somebody smelling you before they see
you become invisible I didn't understand
what that meant
so we went on a three-day Bender didn't
take a shower smell like [ __ ]
no deodorant you know he smelled like a
homeless person you look like a homeless
person and you approach somebody asking
for the time and they smell you before
they see you and you are not there
you're not a human you don't exist
so that was a pretty valuable lesson
that I got there yeah so that that's
interesting but like I have this belief
it has to do with the way I operate in
this world I suppose but if you come off
as a person legitimately I guess you
could fake it but I I think it it just
feels like you can be extremely good
possibly the best in the world
if you practice it your whole life at
being you you yeah being authentic being
it's showing like you have nothing to
hide
and a True Believer is whatever A True
Believer so like yes you can come up
with a fake narrative but then what I
mean is like live that narrative your
whole life then yeah like I understand I
understand and then never falter from
that like you are this person that's
what I'm trying to I have nothing to
hide I consider I consider that a True
Believer and yeah that is a unique
person when you meet them and they are
out there there are people that will
[ __ ] walk into places this is who I
am I don't give a [ __ ] this is who I am
if you don't trust me well shoot me [ __ ]
it
um this is my honesty and if you don't
trust me well look at all these people
that I've interacted with in the past
and you can ask them about it or you can
see my effects on other people that's
going to be my presentation card and so
the way you said it now is using words
and it's blunt usually somebody's blunt
like that like I'm a no [ __ ] person
that means they're not yeah that means
they are full of [ __ ] actually but you
do that through I mean I'm saying I'm
verbalizing your behavior you know just
walking somewhere uh you know let's say
you're going to interview somebody very
dangerous down there and you walk into a
room without worry
that is
that is a presentation to you I know
that's a pretty pretty interesting
introduction
um
you know you're not a threat because you
don't consider yourself a threat and
you're walking in there with the
confidence that you don't consider
yourself as a threat
which is an interesting way of going
about it uh my life experiences has been
different I was in programmed that way
from an early age and uh it's hard to
for me to go into that line
although more and more as I get older
and as I learn more about the world and
I've failed a few more times I can
understand or more cognizant of the fact
that
you don't really have to try that much
if you if you believe in your in
yourself and who you are if you know
yourself that's I think that is at the
core of it if you know yourself enough
to to be able to to kind of communicate
that to people around you and you're not
hiding from yourself or from the world
your flaws too yeah that was the the
thing you spoke to that is probably
inspiring to others is being honest
about your flaws about your weakness as
a human being you can't pick pocket a
naked man and if if you can if you know
how to be naked and again I'm not there
I think I'm I'm working towards that
just by
hopingly going through [ __ ] and uh
showing people not telling them is that
show me don't tell me is another
valuable lesson that I got long ago
um
I I travel across the country and I
don't not only get to show people what I
know how to do but I I I I give examples
of it through things that I do out there
and uh
I say this a lot you know when I travel
out there I'm never alone you know
there's couches out there waiting for me
you know there's uh there's homes that I
can go go and stay at and
friends that I have out there that I
have never even met
but that's been about me not only
worrying some of those mistakes and past
failures on my sleeve but also turning
them into lessons for people
and just telling people the fact that
you know I know how to do all this weird
stuff you know and I show people how to
do it yeah
but here's a bunch of weird memes that
are very humorous about my culture and
about being it through going through
therapy and
this is me doing something Goofy and
this is me being an idiot in front of
all you guys as well you know this is me
being the fool I think that is another
aspect of it I love that as part of that
Journey he made enemies with the rodeo
clown and meet up with them afterwards
oh we're still we're in a very toxic
relationship you know he knows who he is
he's probably out there listening he's
uh loving hey we we're there we we we
stopped talking to each other for months
and then you know just send a thick
message of some sort and just you know
we're back at it you know back yeah love
expressed through anger I love it it's
therapeutic you have both very
interesting career paths if we can just
jump back to in a really interesting
topic that I wanted to mention
um on Narco occultism
what are Narco Cults what's the
relationship between you kind of
mentioned religion a little bit yeah
what's the relationship between
religious culture and drug culture first
off Mexico is one of the most Catholic
countries on the planet if not the most
Catholic country on the planet not only
that it is a country that has a root in
a spirituality through its in ethnic
culture
that you know other other parts of the
world got most of that taken away and or
suppressed or killed or taken away
um when the Spanish came to Mexico they
were a product of a recently liberated
group of people they just got done being
invaded by the Moors basically
and they brought with them the image
Guadalupe
the version of Guadalupe and Hernan
cortes's vision of that version of that
was a lady holding a crystal scepter
baby Jesus and standing on a crescent
moon that's what that's what he brought
with him to the Americas
and uh when the conquest happened you
know a lot of people say the Spanish
came and conquested the mech the the the
Aztec empire
the enemies of the Aztec Allied
themselves with the Spanish and they
took them now that's what happened and
then the rest was famine and sickness
that's what killed most of them
they realized that it was kind of be
hard to suppress some of the spiritual
practices in Mexico so they decided to
meld them with Catholic iconography
so you see these uh this cult to uh to
not scene which is like a fertility
variant of a mother goddess and not the
culture and they turned her into La
VidCon de Guadalupe which is the icon
that a lot of Mexicans venerate as the
levitician the virgin
um but in her she conceals cultural
elements from the past she has a black
sash across her stomach which means
she's pregnant something common in the
Aztec culture and the mahika culture
she's standing on a cherub that has
Eagle wings that is a war god
that's the symbol of the war god down
there she has stars on her which is a
veil of certain stars that are related
to some of the spiritual practice from
before
basically they hid these things in in
that in that uh setting now you skip
forward
you know hundreds of years
and you start seeing things like uh
malverde who was a bandit that lived in
Sinaloa way back in the day he would Rob
Rich Farmers that would go through the
uh the countryside
one time he was almost caught he was
shot and injured and he was wanted by
the government so he told one of his
friends to
tell them where he was and to give the
money the reward money to the
townspeople so we did that
uh the he was hung from a tree and the
the order was not to bury him just to
let his body rot and his body rotted
away until it fell on the ground bones
and each of the townspeople would go
over and put a rock on top of his corpse
until it became a pile of rocks and then
he started granting miracles
so again this whole aspect of these
criminals become in Saints
uh and also the middle finger from the
downward local populace to the uh the
church in a way because there's not a
recognized saint but he has a an altar
and people venerate that
then you have
cartels that have a spiritual practice
or spirituality behind what they do
which is part of their culture but is
also like a tool they use to
ingratiate themselves with the local
populace or the or the population around
them uh their icon icons of power and
sometimes of uh
like I'm almost a symbol of rebellion uh
you see El Chapo's son when he was
arrested had a Santo ninocha on his
chest which is a
it's a holy kid of a torture
the Spanish Legend during the Morris
Conquest uh they said that a statue of
that Saint would go around and feed some
of the hungry you know that was the
legend
and he's a he's a saint of the
persecuted so the fact that when he was
arrested he was you see him with that
wearing wearing that and then he was
liberated is a miracle in and of itself
so it's proof that that works you see
that that was you can find one of those
scapulatios anywhere in Mexico that was
the most highly sold one
um
so you see them utilizing some of these
aspects uh in in their own belief system
to as a similar as I kind of iconography
basically for some of the things they do
then you go into some of the other
aspects of it that are out there like
Santa Muerte which is actually a faith
that I grew up in
Mexico has a real weird relationship to
death
we have parties at the cemetery on Day
of the Dead and we I just went through
one you know recently this is uh
November November the 2nd
so we celebrate our dead and we
celebrate death in a way that I don't
think a lot of cultures out there do
so it's a joyful occasion it is a
celebration yeah my eight-year-old put
two beers on an altar one for my mom one
for my brother
she bought a Snickers bar for my mom and
a a bag of pops for my brother uh flower
petals and marigolds and pictures of
them on an altar that's amazing what
kind of beer
Roja for my mother because he's you know
she was Hardcore and they got the light
from my brother you know he was a more
of a endurance drinker
um and it's also for me yeah the
relationship to death down there is
different uh so there's an icon in
Mexico it's actually one of the fastest
growing
uh alternative spiritual practices in
Mexico and not not only in Mexico but
here in the US I've been to Santa muerta
temples across the country I found one
in Connecticut out of all places
how I grew up with it or I saw it is uh
we would we my family was on
guadalupanas we were we were catholic
and we venerated the version of
Guadalupe specifically the icon of the
version of Guadalupe
but every now and then there are winks
and nods to a skeletal Saint in in in
family practices and even when I went to
work uh
they they got the older guys that were I
was working with would tell me like hey
we gotta go ask uh ask for protection
so they would drive me over to the
church and I thought it was going to the
cathedral and then we made a left turn
and it wasn't the cathedral it was the
Market next to the cathedral in Tijuana
and in the little corner there was a big
Santa Muerte Reaper Refugee and
then I knew why I had to bring a bottle
of tequila I was like why am I bringing
a bottle tequila to the church
it was for her for death la muerte
it was partly hazing
and also they did believe that they were
basically imbued with
the being agents of death in a way so it
was like a cultural thing as well
something that they they wore on them as
not only protection but it's also like a
sound like a samurai would where this
death iconography on them or how
uh the Maori would do uh Haka dances you
know to some of these guys in their kind
of warrior culture that they were
growing up with or trying to in view on
us the young guys
uh they would um take us there and they
wouldn't view us with iconography or
Santa Marta to be like a psychological
thing so that gives you strength and
meaning in the face of struggle like in
the in the face of difficulties in life
I think uh you know if you're closeness
to death and having a relationship to
death in the form of a symbolic
representation of it like Santa Marta or
an icon like that
makes it not as scary I guess or not not
only that but it's also something that
the other side
the enemy the cartels groups they would
venerate it as well so when they would
see it on you it was almost debilitating
to them they were like oh are you guys
cops are you guys why why are you
wearing that
uh so it was an aspect of that to it uh
a
momentumori type thing where you'll
remember death you know type thing
there's some aspect in which you don't
want to mess with the person who
meditates on death there was some of
that yeah
there was a saying I think they probably
took it from a movie or something like
that but I don't know where they got it
uh mayor may I earn your need and be
your Wrath
oh man it's a good line they would say
that to the Statue of la Santa you know
another thing people it's not a cartel
specific Saint though it's like
everybody like at all levels from the
lady that sells tortillas
to the um
to the cops to the military there's some
people in the military that venerated uh
there's a there's a very specific symbol
of how this is like a weird relationship
in the specifically in Santa Marta in
Mexico
there's a there's a shrine outside of
Tijuana right across the uh
La Presa it's like a water reservoir
right in South Tijuana
and there was a big Santa Muerte uh
altar there like on the roadside
and my former boss Lisa Ola ordered that
thing destroyed
so the the he boarded a truck to destroy
it it was a famous thing
and it was rebuilt the next night and I
know for a fact that some of the people
that rebuilt that were some of the same
guys that you know were destroying
oh man that's pretty symbolic so it's
just it's not something that can be
killed it's a part of the the spirit of
the people it keeps getting destroyed by
Ultra Christian groups or Catholic
groups and it keeps getting rebuilt
personally for me as a
you know it's I don't believe that
there's a a Reaper skeleton in the sky
protecting me
uh but I do believe in the aspect of an
ending you know and how it's important
to you know the ending is important in
all things and death should be present
in life and if it's not then you're
delusional about things
so the to you it's a mechanism to
meditate on death once again yeah and
you know having uh my daughter who's
eight
uh be who it has a benevolent thing you
know she's a kid and she sees a skeleton
that represents death and Jesus does
it's like
I think uh
in a way Mexicans have taken some of
those aspects be it Day of the Dead some
of these practices related to some
occultism aspects around uh you know
Saint Judas you know son cudas Saint
Judas is the the patron state of lost
causes
and it's one of the most venerated
Saints in Mexico you know you know Jesus
is probably like on the fourth or fifth
he prayed which is pretty funny
ridiculous but the reason why and this
is something I heard from somebody that
uh was actually we found him with a gun
and on his gun he had a Saint Judas
effigy
and he said well like why is
and he's like well he's the last Saint
you prayed to
what do you mean well on the list of
saints you prayed to he's the last one
because when you pray to Judas you might
get the other Judas on the line yeah
that's the last one you pray to that's
why he's like the Lost Cause of Saint I
remember like
even how we try and bribe or like
maneuver our way into human in
spirituality it's spiritual practices
yeah you know such a fascinating culture
that doesn't like anything else
and it's right next door
and it's here too again uh I I found an
altar in Connecticut which is pretty
fascinating there's one in Arizona
and again it's one of the fastest
growing spiritual practices in in the in
not only in the US but like across
there's
uh somebody from Russia reached out
there's an altar out there and there's a
group of people praying to Santa Marta
and I've been posting and writing a lot
about it recently just from my own
experience and some of the stuff that I
gathered for myself and
all the way out there
you know people are fascinated by some
of those aspects so I got to ask you
about the dark turn of of that
spirituality or maybe you will place
this elsewhere but who was Adolfo
castanzo Al padrino this is a guy that
comes up in a period I think is he's
he's at the that initial period of
cartels this is before my time and I've
I've talked to some of the people that
were there for some of that I mean he
kills a lot of people he was exposed and
learned uh through his family ties about
some of the afro-caribbean
spiritualities that are now also
exploding as far as influences across
the world uh Latin America and and in
the US when I talk about that I mean
Santeria
basically some old spiritual practices
Coming Out of Africa that uh
utilize things like in gangas which are
basically spiritual vessels that have to
be loaded with human remains in some
cases
he was basically a spiritual
practitioner that certain cartel groups
would hire for them to curse the other
side to imbue them with invisibility to
be able to transport their drugs or
protection spells and stuff like that he
was very successful at it apparently or
at least that is the experience of the
people paying for some of these
practices
as his spells and his work kept getting
bigger and bigger and more and more and
complicated the
ingredients he needed for these in
gangas or these spells these cauldrons
that he would fill with
certain elements grew in complexity
till finally he said he needed the brain
of a highly educated American of some
sort
which led to his eventual downfall he
was basically responsible for abducting
and murdering a young American who's a
university uh college student I think
Jinky believed
the so this guy's murdering people to
create what magical potions uh vessels
yeah vessels I think yeah I think I
think he truly believed that he was uh
capable of doing what he was doing I
guess and there's a culture
that's spiritually inclined that kind of
was on the same wavelength as him yeah
it jived I mean some of these spiritual
practices again there's there's a
ritualistic cannibalism done by some of
these cartel groups out there was he
involved in in cannibalism as well he
wasn't involved in cannibalism that I
know of but uh most of the things that
he was kind of known for was basically
requesting human body parts for some of
the spell Works he was doing and then
going to such a level where he needed a
specific brain head of somebody that was
educated and American so that kind of
again led to his uh eventual downfalls
his Ranch was rated they found the body
parts inside of these conference that he
was preparing
that's an interesting example of
somebody there's a cartel head somewhere
in central Mexico as well
uh El masloko was his nickname
and he basically forced the citizenship
around him to turn him into a saint
so he like he made a statue of himself
he was very big into uh Christianity
specifically kind of like the uh
crusader
you know mentality and all that kind of
imbued himself and some of the people
that were around him uh with that
and they're still altars to his death to
him after he died he died two times one
time the government declared him you
that he was killing a shootout and turns
out he wasn't dead
so that was his first miracle you know
and then when he was really dead uh some
of his people and his loyal followers
were like gunpoint kind of still forced
to go and you know get flowers and
venerate this these Effigies and statues
of of him as a saint
it's a powerful weapon spirituality in
Mexico is a powerful weapon and
you know the Church Catholic Church in
Mexico was a pretty bad track record but
as far as them control as far as that
being used to control populace and stuff
like that
um and I think uh it's just another
aspect that is being exploited in Mexico
in some communities as far as the
spirituality and the desperate need for
people to believe in something
and how that leads for some people to go
into some horrible predatory behavior
around it this is a fascinating Dynamic
of play here so it's not just the United
States and Mexico it's also China that
you talk about
China is the primary source of fentanyl
in the world
so fentanyl is an opioid that leads to
70 000 plus or minus overdose deaths in
the US every year
So reading from Wikipedia called
compared with Heroin it is more potent
has higher profit margins
and because it is compact has simpler
Logistics it can be cut into or even
replaced entirely the supply of heroin
and other opiates what do you think is
important to understand about fentanyls
as a drug there was a prescription
opioid epidemic in the United States
that kind of
went down or stopped you know well you
know still out there but like the
epidemic specific around it uh kind of
petered out and there was also marijuana
legalization
happening at kind of the same time
period
which uh you know people talking about
marijuana legalization thought it was
going to hit the cartels in their
pockets and it was going to be like a
you know a death blow to these criminal
groups
well now there's a illegal pot grows in
the United States being run by cartels
in federal lands there's the legal pot
grows that are in some way shape or form
influence and or run or owned by some
camera groups that are kind of utilizing
that
the the marijuana fields in Mexico turn
into poppy fields once again
the problem is that some of these lands
were leached of all the nutrients and
you know they're not as good as
something you would find somewhere in
Afghanistan so the the yield and the
quality of it wasn't as strong as it
could be
so somebody thought about the right idea
of putting fentanyl into the mix
and not only that but also figuring out
a get fentanyl into Mexico
has a giant pharmaceutical industry that
people kind of also don't kind of know
or factor into this equation which leads
into
the free ability of chemicals going in
and out of the country and legal means
of it happening right so not only the
precursors to make it but also the
chemists then the industry to create it
in Mexico as well
some clandestine factories of fentanyl
have been found in Mexico
but realistically it's not needed with
the with the ways that the ports and the
borders are down in Mexico
um
you started seeing an influx and a flood
of uh fentanyl into Mexico specifically
related to infusing it into heroin
and not only using that to feed local
drug markets but send it up into the
United States which started off this
process that we're kind of going through
still are these like similar highs and
drug-wise why do you infuse I mean
probably you're not the right person to
have this biochemical discussion or how
I don't know about the biochemical
aspect of it but like speaking to guys
that do Chiva down there that's what
they do that's that's what we call
heroin down there it's like a nickname
for it uh having them describe uh some
of the older stinkier darker heroin they
used to get before this whole fentanyl
thing and the highs they would get and
how much they would have to take versus
some of the stuff loaded with fentanyl
that they have to
you know also there's more higher
potency yeah there's a higher potency to
it and also there's a you know more
money to be made easier to transport
yeah but then
is this how China starts becoming part
of the picture one aspect to it that
people kind of Miss is that you know
there's no Chinese cartel you know
there's no criminal Chinese organization
working unseen getting around government
oversight in China
I don't know of any any such organisms
anything that could be labeled as a
criminal organization is is uh deeply
integrated with the government so it's I
mean I've never heard of a giant
criminal Enterprise in China operating
so we have to assume then independent of
the state I would I would have to assume
that some of these things are happening
with the know-how and inaction of the
government out there
um when covet hit there was a shortage
of fentanyl on the Northern side of
Mexico specifically related to the Tina
law cartel these guys were actually
trafficking fentanyl from the U.S down
to Mexico to infuse their product
but not the new generation cartel which
operates out of the central part of
Mexico Colima area which have access to
the seaside ports
so even during the shutdown they were
getting supplied
which means to me at least we're first
anybody observing it that the supply
chain was not cut
and whatever was coming out of China was
being let out of China by by whatever
official channels would be able to shut
down or stop it and I would love to know
the organizational structure the
governmental structure of China
how they enable it
because I can't imagine
at the very top there's like a portfolio
of things we're doing and one of them is
not the most right I I think it's more
in action or just the note knows how
that is happening but just like hands
off just let this FL I I don't know if I
were to understand how large
bureaucracies work it's looking the
other way yeah you are now seeing
um pill presses brought to Mexico
Industrial Level pill presses found in
clandestine Laboratories
where they're not only infusing the the
the the yields that they're doing with
fentanyl but also making fake pain
medication that is flooding U.S markets
everywhere less Rarities
is that pain medication or is that
fentanyl you know who knows and that's
how you see a lot of people dying from
ODS that are supposedly taking pain
pills and that's not what they're doing
uh so the evolution right now you're
seeing is
making something
look legit as far as pain medication
that isn't and I mean fentanyl is
everywhere they're infusing cocaine with
it
I've been getting stories from the US of
people buying it through Alibaba or just
weird online sources and it coming in
different packages and just infusing it
into into whatever is out there
it is killing off a whole generation of
people
um and it comes from one place or it's
manufactured somewhere where it's being
manufactured with the precursors and the
elements and know-how that comes from
one place
are we talking about China talking about
China because Mexico seems to have
what's the world this is such a
complicated and how do you start to talk
about the drug war when more and more
and more
China
is the source of the drug
is there a drug war going on with China
there's probably an economic War well
you talk about you there's another side
to China
uh most and this is something that's
come out recently a few years back I
think but basically the ways you would
move money back into Mexico after you
have a load up here is that you would
give it to a Chinese money broker they
would put into the Chinese banking
system and it immediately it would just
disappear from American eyes
and then another money broker in Mexico
would receive it through a money
transfer from China so China's
incredibly good amount of money
laundering
that's another aspect I mean their
banking system is invisible to the US
basically which allows which allows the
Monies to move from one point to another
so money Brokers and people moving money
for for for the groups down there are
Chinese so that's another aspect the
element of China as far as its presence
what's the role of intelligence in all
of this FBI CIA the Chinese intelligence
uh agencies right now Mexico is going
through uh
a nationalistic Resurgence and leftist
presidency
which is not friendly to U.S interest in
a lot of ways
the U.S has had a pretty bad track
record when it's with its foreign policy
in Mexico with a lot of damage being
done by the last president as far as his
rhetoric uh Donald Trump which has been
weaponized and utilized by the by the
left down down in Mexico
so America has not seen uh positively no
every now and then I post something
about Mexico some horrible thing
happening down there it's like why
doesn't us send people down there like
are Mexicans looking for like U.S
intervention it's like no
that is beyond what anybody in Mexico
would want us specifically you see that
the sentiment out there
they don't view the us as a as somebody
that's going to come in and fix anything
or somebody that's going to help or as a
friend uh with the when the Ukrainian
conflict happened
uh Mexico basically is abstained from
saying anything
which is a winking and not to Russia it
has openly been pro-madural and openly
celebrated some of these uh regimes be
popping up uh across Latin America
you know which is
that is what people voted for that is a
sentiment down there they're going
towards the left of the political
spectrum because they've been basically
violated over and over again by all
these different presidencies that have
promised changed brought corruption with
them and they are our choices so this is
this is the best we have right now uh
and all of the enemies of the United
States are taking full advantage of that
you know we recently had a general kind
of address a senate committee hearing I
think he was talking about the
prevalence of foreign intelligence
services in Mexico you know and why that
is
well you know it has Mexico has a lot of
the Mind of a lithium on the planet
underneath the parts of it specifically
in the North
at uh it is going through a process they
call it the La Cuarta transformation on
the fourth the fourth transformation is
what the president of Mexico calls it
which is uh in a way it's basically
we're here to stay type thing
you know they just uh nationalized
mining lithium and taking control of
that and using that as leverage if the
United States ever wants to go to Mexico
it's probably not going to be related to
cartel issues it's going to probably
relate to energy I think you know so
they're kind of thinking ahead I guess
well what about also just imagine a
world
where India and China are doing fentanyl
trade with Mexico or whatever transport
imagine Chinese military
moves makes an agreement a NATO type of
agreement with Mexico that's pretty
possible again we're seeing a
militarized Mexico it's another aspect
of Mexico that again I haven't seen
talked about a lot here in the U.S
the main problem is that the current
president had was he was going to make
the police the federal police and the
the the the security issues in Mexico
civil civilian he was gonna do exactly
the opposite as his main rival Felipe
Calderon the guy that started off the
drug war officially
and what does he do he dissolves the
civilian leadership of the federal
police dissolves the federal police
creates the National Guard which is a
military unit and he puts the military
in charge of that
now the military has a full Monopoly
over all federal policing there when you
cross into Mexico you'll see them
wearing these white camouflage uniforms
those are
those are National Guard people but
they're they're they're the military so
now you're seeing a military rise in
Mexico with some of these leaks that
happened during the guacamaya the
guacamaya leagues you're now seeing that
Mexico has been hosting members of the
Haitian military and they've been
training them up to go back to police
their country
that's not something that Mexico has
been known for to hosting other nations
and and training them in such a way so
it's like a it's a it's an interesting
maneuver like Mexico has been
historically neutral about getting
involved in foreign conflicts about
voting and resolutions as far as
invading or not invading or doing all
these things
Mexico has been historically kind of
neutral when it comes to some of these
things and now we're training foreign
military forces to go and do that role
somewhere else
um we have the military building
airports and building infrastructure in
Mexico when a lot of their higher ups
getting very you know wealthy around it
you know and they basically have a
monopoly over
you know who gets to have guns down
there you know there's one gun store in
all Mexico and it's run by the military
and the only way you can buy a gun there
is if you can buy a plane ticket to fly
there and have enough money to sustain
that uh that right or that privilege
So you you're seeing the military not
being in its traditional role of just
being the security Force now it's
policing it's involved in it's it's
getting involved in politics in a big
way you know it's uh legislation that
has passed to keep it on the streets and
the policing role for more years now so
that should be looked at Closer by
anybody observing it uh from afar how
the militarization of Mexico and where
it's going because if you move towards a
world where a world war three happens it
feels like Mexico will be the center
because a hot War would be fought on the
ground
and so you have a very difficult
parallel between Mexico and Ukraine both
don't have nuclear weapons both have
relationships so Ukraine has a
relationship or a pull towards the
European Union and NATO
Mexico at least currently has a kind of
slow pull towards China India
potentially and Russia and you have this
divide between power centers in the
world
and in terms of just imagine
hundreds of thousands of Mexican troops
hundreds of thousands of Chinese troops
on the border
on the U.S border yeah on the Mexican
side and also the fact that that border
doesn't mean anything to any sort of
conflict that would happen regionally
because that that's a very easy to
cross-border doesn't matter how many
walls you put across it people are
already here uh this is not going to be
a war fought off in some overseas place
like you're not gonna this is something
if if it happens if destabilization is
utilized in Mexico
to cause a conflict there and it turns
into a Vietnam or a proxy war down there
of a sword which I think
in a way you're already kind of seeing
some of that uh through some of the
conflicts going on down there you have a
a new generation cartel that is being
fed fentanyl from the Pacific side ports
and
and suspiciously you know you you want
to think that maybe it's favored by a
foreign government of some sort uh in
some way shape or form uh who knows and
then you have a historically in control
seen in law cartel that Miron may not be
favored by the U.S in some way shape or
form
you can imagine a further conflict down
there and people fostering it and seeing
the effects of basically setting a fire
on the feet of the United States its
second largest consumer of U.S products
is Mexico
um the massive wave of immigration that
is going to be basically weaponized uh
you know you saw the collapse of the
border security structure with the
contingent of three thousand Honduran
Guatemalan immigrants in that first the
wave of uh Caravans coming to Tijuana
you saw it was it was pretty bad you
know it was pretty bad it could have
gotten worse
now what is going to happen when that
wave is no not no longer 3 000 but you
know a million people being displaced by
violence or being
in fear of whatever conflict might
originate down there and just that
massive wave of migration and move like
I think that that's a that's an
interesting thing that people should
look at and you know how can you affect
change to try and stop some of the these
things that happen
well let me ask you to philosophical at
a human level what do you think about
immigration
a legal and legal immigration
from the direction of Mexico to the
United States so we have an estimated 11
million illegal immigrants in the United
States
and uh estimated 45 million legal
immigrants a few things about that when
cobit hit there was no shortages of uh
produce on the in the supermarkets
which means that I mean illegal
immigration is pretty much the backbone
of all uh produce and some of the
farming Industries out there you know
most of it
so illegal immigration and illegal
illegal workers in those fields are
essential workers in a way
I think there's a weird relationship in
the United States with some of these
workers and how they're demonized and
how they're called criminals I think
there's
there was a state out there that passed
anti-illegal immigrant uh worker
legislation the farmers had to look
elsewhere for for uh people to show up
to work in some of these fields which
basically caused millions of dollars
worth of losses for some of these uh
Farms
um anywhere you go out there in the
United States you go into the kitchens
and there's going to be Paisanos there
you know French high-level French
restaurants
you'll see people from Puebla there that
uh made their way illegal and might have
legalized regularized regularized their
way into the country or or in a
sanctuary City
uh you go to the service industry hotels
you know those are the people changing
the blankets those are the people in the
washrooms
you have them doing jobs that no
American wants to do realistically and
they're everywhere in this country and
they are the backbone of some of these
industries that are essential in this
country do you think there's a deep
sense in which they are American I think
they're indispensable and anybody that
says they aren't
is delusional if you take every single
allele worker out of the industry in the
United States and send them back like
there's a movie out there called like
yes a day without Mexicans
you know
everything would stop so the the
relationship is there uh people talk
about the history of slavery in this
country like it's a thing that's in the
past
uh there's endangered the endangered
slaves in the country right now people
that are paying off their their people
Smugglers because they brought them into
this country and they haven't been able
to pay that fine with that fee yet
and are basically being held hostage by
that here in the United States so
they're slaves right now in the United
States you know people are talking about
it's a historical context
what do we do about it how are we
supposed to think about it we're going
to have to rethink how we look at
immigration illegal or illegal or
illegal or legal immigration from Mexico
and how we view Mexico as a as a foreign
country
um your relationship to Canada is one
thing your relationship to Mexico is
another
the foreign policy towards Mexico has
been pretty nefarious in the as far as
the United States in a lot of ways you
know you can go back there was a student
Massacre during the Olympics
and the president in turn at that time
was a c on the CIA payroll and it was a
counter communist type maneuver that
we're doing down there
but there's some bloody hands on on the
U.S side but of some of the things that
have been happening in Mexico as far as
destabilization and influencing and
meddling and foreign policy out there
most of the guns that are used down
there come from the US you know and
that's a that's another interesting
aspect and responsibility that people
should kind of think about up here so
there is on the drug war side a machine
that's fueling the drug war I mean
there's a giant drug habit up here you
know but also a governmental
intelligence and Military Support
through the sale of weapons I don't know
about the cell weapons but you know
there's some very
you talk about poorest borders uh coming
up there's poorest borders also going
down you know there's there's a flow of
guns going down and munitions
which again they don't kill anybody by
themselves you know they put the get put
in the hands of the desperate that are
trying to feed a giant drug Market
that's out to the north you know Mexico
has a saying Mexico Mexico
far from God but close to the United
States right uh and uh there's uh
there's definitely a responsibility on
both sides this is no longer a Mexico
problem a U.S problem this is a regional
problem
and if we don't think of it as a
regional problem with our brothers on
the southern side of it and with family
we're we're related in blood there's
like we are we are Mexico in the United
States are like this
but it's become popular in politics they
just throw a line
right and I think we need to get to a
place where we can figure out how to
make those connections and repair some
of the Damage Done by like just years
and years of uh bad policy on both sides
of the Border policy and rhetorically we
talk about the way we think about it not
just the actual policy but uh seeing the
humanity and the people that are here
yeah it's an easy thing they're coming
to take our jobs is something you hear
there was a state out there that passed
them uh anti-uh
anti-legislation as far as illegal
workers on fields and it led to massive
losses nobody wanted to show up for
those jobs basically the people would
show up one day and they wouldn't come
back and they were doing jobs that
people just don't want to do
are they taking that from the locals or
are they feeling an essential role that
we feel guilty about and the rhetoric
around it is more about guilt
than anything
um I am an immigrant myself you know I
I've gone through the experience of
doing it legally and
I've seen people not do it legally and
are in way better places than I am
basically uh by going around some of the
system
um the system itself the immigration
system here in the US is this is there's
something wrong you know it's kind of
broken
um
and people coming here illegally are not
only you know they're looking for a
better life for themselves a better life
for people this whole aspect of
vilifying them and they're like oh
there's the there's this immigrant did
this horrible thing this immigrant did
that horrible thing and uh people call
it saying you know go back to your
country at the same time they go to a
hotel where they're all the service
staff is from that part of the world and
they're here irregularly or they go to
the you know the Whole Foods and they
get some produce there and it's picked
by some of the same people they're
vilifying again we need to kind of like
think about that and analyze that for
ourselves like this yeah the idea of go
back to your country and finding the
other and having a disdain and a hate
towards the other ever since I had a
recent conversation with yay formerly
known as Kanye West I got to hear a few
things from
let's say unfriendly messages from White
nationalists
and I got to learn about this world uh I
continue on the Journey of learning
which is the idea that the United States
this country should look a certain way
should have a certain skin color should
have a certain religion and everything
else is a pollution is a poison to this
I made it sound hateful right now but
they usually frame it in a positive way
like the Purity I'm sure Hitler also
phrased everything in a positive way
especially in the 1930s about the purity
of Germany but the reality of the United
States and one of the things that makes
it
at least the idea of the United States
is the soup the mix unlike So Many
Nations I've I've traveled to there's
the the diversity the good kind of
diversity is what makes this country
great and uh there's so I think it's it
needs to be based on the
accepting the different subgroups that
make up the United States versus trying
to purify it I think Mexican immigrants
is just another flavor of saying this is
the other let's reject the other yeah I
saw that interview by the way that was
that that you showed a basic restraint
in an interview
my experience and I I came up here again
Trump was elected when I was when I came
up here so it was a weird time for me as
far as being an immigrant in the
Immigrant experience for myself
um by both being you know basically the
bad the the ones that were you know
talked about in that way and also having
a bunch of my friends who were very
conservative and you know wearing some
of those Mega hats around me and like
hey Ed like like well I mean you know
you know I'm a guest here so I have to
you know but uh
it's a balancing act is what I've been
looking at it as you know on one side
there's the woke side of it which
everything goes and then the other side
is like let's hold on to some of these
things that make us who we are
on my end you know I want to get to a
place where I can smoke a joint uh
concealed carrier firearm be it my gay
best friend's wedding and I want the
government not to say anything about it
and I think there's Parts in the United
States here that kind of feel the same
way but there's extremes on both sides
that are pulling you to one side or the
other
and I've seen more of the United States
than most Americans I'm in a different
state every weekend so I get to go to I
going to Tampa tomorrow
then I'm going back to California then
I'm from Tennessee later and Kentucky so
I get to see all types of people and all
types of mentalities and and ways that
people live in this country is more
diverse than most would think you know
if you only see it through the lens of
television or media
what I keep seeing out there that for me
is like a
the reason I came here I guess and a lot
of a lot of the reasons that I feel a
vested interest in this country not just
because of can my kids American so I
have a very very big interest in this
country doing well but I think I see is
the there's still the opportunity and
the ability to do something with
yourself and and opportunities out there
for people like me that come here with
nothing I came here with
an experience space
a truck
and some demons and uh yeah and a bunch
of demons in a bag and I'm here with you
talking right now about some of those
experiences and another immigrant
another to another immigrant and both of
us are reaching people out there that uh
you know might not might haven't heard a
voice of people like us that come that
come here with our own bag of uh demons
but where else in the world can two
people like us have a conversation with
a with an audience like us and not be uh
shot outside of of this because of the
stuff we're saying yeah listen to was uh
with with love and respect not
not uh derision
um
let me ask you for advice what what
would you say to Young Folks
wherever they come from so in high
school and college they're thinking of
how to live
a life have a career they can they can
be proud of and especially if they're
struggling especially if they're at a
low Point like you are when you came
here
a travel travel is one of the biggest
things in the world that I would ask
people to kind of go out to uh see how
other people live don't go there with
your own preconceived notions or trying
to make people act like you act like go
out there and travel and actually
experience the world
it doesn't have to be another country uh
going from uh Tennessee to Seattle you
know it's a pretty interesting uh change
of uh a scenery who's put on knife
fighting just kidding you don't have to
answer that uh that's fantastic but but
uh the uh traveling is one and knowing
how other people live uh is one aspect
of it that would tell people uh it's
risky it's dangerous but that is part of
the journey is one of the things I would
ask people uh young people to kind of
like consider
service is essential and it should be at
the basis of all of our Lives service
start there start with service
in any industry you're going to go start
your own restaurant you have to work in
the kitchen for service if you're going
to be a part a productive member of this
country service and I'm not talking just
about the military because the military
it's it's a process and it's a lifestyle
and it's a thing for some people out
there it's not even a choice for other
people if they want an education and I
get that community service of any kind
is an essential thing the ability to go
out there and interact with the people
that you would normally not interact
with the homeless population that you
know that is in this country uh the the
older population that uh in Mexico or
our old die in our homes you know uh you
know but here you send them off
somewhere else to die which is an
interesting weird Detachment that I've
seen in the US as far as how the elders
are are cast aside uh if I can say
anything to young people is to start
figuring out our Life's a service and
that's gonna that's gonna expose you to
a bunch of experiences to a bunch of
people out there you might not regularly
kind of meet and see and realities
education
is out there
it is expensive but I've sat through a
bunch of really expensive classes that
I've managed to see on YouTube and
learned a lot from them
uh so education is out there but it
doesn't have to be as expensive as they
as they make it it's all about the
individual and what he does without
education
the dream is free and the hustle is sold
separately is something else I watch
somewhere in uh online but the ability
to take take information process and use
it uh we're expecting everything to be
safe processed and given to us in a
platter and taking that and digesting
and thinking that's going to make us
somebody that's going to be productive
or valuable in society
that's up to us
the US talks a lot about freedoms but
doesn't talk a lot about
responsibilities I think that's a big
part of you know take responsibility for
[ __ ] like I came here without anything
and the first thing I thought was I have
a responsibility for the people that
I've
worked with and the people that are
going through the same problem the same
problems than I am how can I figure out
a way to help
yeah the Dark Side of thinking a lot
about freedom is thinking too
individualistically meaning thinking
about me how to optimize my situation
forgetting that the deepest growth
you can do as an individual is by taking
care of others by helping others by
being of service by being useful to your
community locally and then hopefully
also at scale and that's how you grow
and that's responsibility of like
helping those around you there's an
isolationist aspect to culture now it's
like we we're separate there's a there's
almost like a spiritual or cultural
amputation in a way where
you know when when I was a kid the house
where all the bikes outside of it that
that was where all the kids were hanging
out
and now everybody's on their phone you
know in the separate houses I chatting
on whatever
um
there's a Detachment to there that's a
it's a weird aspect to it and also the
the the aspect of I'm I need to be safe
I can't be offended don't hurt me say
spaces this is my right this is my this
is my right this is my reality you need
to respect it
yeah respect is earned and my when where
I come from respect is earned
um their freedoms but there's dangerous
freedoms those are those any freedom you
have in Mexico is a dangerous freedom in
a way you know you can drive home drunk
in Mexico you can if you bribe a cop on
your way there and if you don't die or
crash into somebody else that's a
dangerous aspect of Freedom uh but
there's a responsibility to all of it
it is a twisted responsibility and a
stress Twisted way kind of talk about
and describe it but I think the the
aspect of people screaming for Freedom
up here or their rights or their
privilege without the responsibility you
know you know what are you doing for
your community you know what you're
complaining about this what are you
doing about it you know another thing
I've noticed in traveling around it's
scary is the whole people people getting
shouted down or canceled because of what
the express or say
some of the creepiest experiences I've
had in the US has been through
universities or so just seeing young
people that have an opinion that is
completely outside of reality you know
um people telling me how things are in
Mexico because they learned it through a
college course yes and seeing sons of
immigrants
criticizing me because of my opinion of
Mexico or what I have to say about it
and you know if you want to encounter
the worst enemy of a Mexican is usually
a second third generation Mexican up
here that uh shouts you down for what
you're saying I mean in general
entitlement all those kinds of things I
I some of that comes with just being
young in general but yes humility
uh humility at a societal scale would
benefit significantly especially the
young so I I would say some of the
service that you're speaking to is comes
with being humbled yeah and that that is
one of the best things you can do as a
young person whilst maintaining the
dream and the ambition humble yourself
to the reality of the world yeah one
small example a micro example of this uh
my kid
there was a homeless guy uh she was out
with some with family members this oh my
God homeless guy showed up he was
erratic mentally mentally Disturbed
previous scene she was upset
there was a little bit of trauma there
she was like oh now all homeless people
are bad
so with her she does art pieces
sometimes for me and helps me make
designs for the clothing brand that I
have
and we take some of that money and we
buy socks and underwear you know
and I sometimes I have them in the car
sometimes I drive around see somebody
need something and I give it to her and
says you helped me earn this money
that's going to help these people so you
should just give them these and she's
like yeah
and like ah thank you and she's like hey
cool rolls out the window uh she used to
roll up the window really quick now she
doesn't
cease to be scary yeah because now some
of them have names now some of them know
her name you know when when they when
she crosses by there so she's there's
contact there she's more connected than
I am in some of these places now you
know she has Friends in Low Places
and in high places that comes later I
guess but she is learning about service
she's learning about not every not not
everybody out there is an enemy or bad
or scary
is he learning about service
and she's uh basically learning that
lesson that I got from my mom long ago
you know nobody's against you they're
for themselves don't take anything
personal
and if you're not doing something for
other people while you're working then
you're not doing anything
so when you were young you were pretty
sure you're gonna die before you're 30.
yeah what's your relationship with death
today do you think about your mortality
are you afraid of it I'm not afraid of
it if anything I'm afraid of uh
meaningless
death or at least a mean a meaningless
uh walk towards it
I'm afraid of losing use of my legs I
guess I'm afraid of not being able to go
out there and do things anymore I'm
afraid that I'm not physically capable
of doing the job that I used to do
uh so if anything I'm afraid of
Stillness you know it's something I
always quote a lot in my writing
Stillness is death
so you always want to be challenging
yourself moving growing like you're
traveling so you get all these
experiences and filling your life with
all these experiences and if it ends
when it ends you're ready for it yeah
I'm not afraid of the end the ending is
important in all things
first time I got a promotion I got two
silver coins handed to me
there's a silver coin and this is
another silver coin and the
he said I'll give you the the other one
when your job ends
yeah
it depends on you if you wanted to have
it over your eyes or in your pocket
right and uh the lesson there is that uh
you know this job you're getting it's
pretty cool and you're going to be in
charge of all these people and it's
pretty important but it's gonna end
so you always have to the ending is
important in all things
um if we don't keep that in mind then if
you think we're Immortal and nothing's
going to end I think that's a there's an
atrophy a spiritual atrophy in that
for the sake of spiritual flourishing
this conversation too must come to an
end so I think a beautiful way to end it
and I'm a huge fan of yours thank you
for
being a man with a life well lived and
for talking with me today is an honor
man it was an awesome conversation I
thank you for having me on
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Ed Calderon to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description and now let
me leave you with some words from Al
Pacino's character and Scarface Tony
Montana
you don't have the guts to be where you
want to be you need people like me so
you can point your fingers and say
that's the bad guy
thanks for listening I hope to see you
next time